So, da bin ich.
Warte mal, mal was gucken.
Pock, pock, pock, pock, pock.
Äh, was ist das hier?
Okay.
Ja, okay.
So, okay. Nice.
Haha,
Kauge der Streben an. Ist irgendwelches Gespamme
am Start, Alter.
Noch bevor
Modgis am Start sind.
Das selbst löschen.
Ja, ähm, das hat mich jetzt etwas
aus dem Konzept gebracht. Ich hatte gerade
irgendwas im Kopf, wo ich gedacht habe, ey, das muss ich
euch mal erzählen, aber
ja, da komme ich bestimmt gleich wieder drauf.
Ach ja,
ähm, die ganzen Sachen, die ich beim
Prime Day bestellt habe, sind mittlerweile da.
Also die Steckdosen sind da.
Die,
was habe ich denn alles bestellt? Die,
ich muss mal kurz bei Amazon reingucken. Sekunde, Leute.
Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr.
Ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr, was da alles dabei ist.
Ah ja, ah ja, genau, also.
Die Steckdosen,
die Milf,
die Milf-Steckdosen,
der Name macht mich immer noch fertig.
Die Steckdosen sind da.
Das Thermostat ist da.
Der Presence Detection Sensor
ist da.
Der Thread-Sigbee-Stick
Ja, und das andere Zeug ist nicht relevant
für hier, für den Stream.
Ein Problem gibt es allerdings mit den
Steckdosen.
Ich habe es gestern schon mal ganz kurz
ausprobiert. Also ich rede hier,
das ist das Einzige,
dass ich hier nach diesen
Buchstaben im Stream suche.
Ich habe so ein Billigpack
Steckdosen bestellt bei Amazon
für 9 Euro, nicht 9,39,
das gab es beim Prime Day
für 9 Euro.
Für 9 Euro,
weil es gab es billiger
am Prime Day
und es gab es nochmal irgendwie
10% oder 20% billiger mit
irgendeinem Coupon oder so dabei.
Also 50% billiger sogar.
Also ich habe 9 Euro bezahlt
für 4 Steckdosen.
Was ich gestern gemacht habe, ich habe gestern mal
ganz ganz auf die schnelle
Raspberry Pi versucht OTA zu flashen.
OTA flashen hat nicht funktioniert,
aber ich habe
eine davon aufgeschraubt.
Ich habe die jetzt hier gerade vor mir.
Man sieht glaube ich,
ich muss mal kurz gucken,
wie sind die Dinger?
KS 520 oder so?
Ah, ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe es vergessen,
wie die Dinger hießen.
Steht da irgendwas?
Hier KS 501,
nicht 520, 501.
Genau, es gibt nämlich Leute,
die haben davon schon Bilder gemacht.
So sieht das von innen aus.
Und was man hier schön sieht ist,
guckt mal, da ist bei mir,
also bei ihm und bei mir,
ist da ein alter Bekannter drauf.
Hier oben.
Erkennt ihr es, was es ist?
Die Beleuchtung bei dem ist ein bisschen schlecht auf dem Bild.
Aber das Logo kennt ihr wahrscheinlich, gell?
Das ist ein ESP8266.
Also das heißt,
der ist prinzipiell noch kompatibel mit Tasmota.
Und das ist,
also das ist wirklich klein.
Das ist sehr integrated hier.
Was ich gefunden habe ist,
die haben tatsächlich
unter,
unter den,
ach gucke mal,
auf dem Bild hat er das gar nicht.
Nehmen wir mal,
das ist die falsche Seite.
Das ist die falsche Seite.
Ne, doch, richtig.
Er hat das nicht.
Okay, nice.
Wisst ihr was, ich hab,
ich hab Debug,
ich hab Debug-Anschlüsse auf meiner,
auf meiner Steckdose drauf.
Die sind,
die sind genau hier drunter.
Also entweder bin ich blind
oder bei dem Modell,
wo er fotografiert hat,
gab's die noch nicht.
Ich hab hier Debug-Anschlüsse dran.
Das heißt,
wenn wir Glück haben,
können wir es darüber flashen.
Ich zeige euch das.
Wir machen heute Abend
ein bisschen Bastel,
Bastelstriebe.
Oder mal gucken,
ob das heute Abend noch hinhaut.
Ja.
Hier hab ich Debug-Anschlüsse.
Hat er nicht.
Mit, äh,
3,3 Volt,
RX,
TX,
Ground
und Reset.
Das sollte theoretisch,
außer wir müssen,
ne,
sollte theoretisch zum Flashen
hiervon reichen.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Das gucken wir uns heute Abend mal an,
ob das,
ob das funktioniert,
ob ich das
mit nem
Serial-Flash-Gerät
geflasht bekomme.
Was sein kann,
wo wir echt Probleme haben,
Probleme haben werden,
ist,
wenn GPIO 0,
GPIO 0 ist der hier,
wenn man den auf Ground machen muss,
dass man flashen kann.
Dann wird's schwierig,
weil das ist so mikroskopisch klein,
das krieg ich wahrscheinlich nicht gebacken.
Aber das schauen wir uns mal,
mal gucken,
ob ich,
ob ich's heute Abend noch mache,
aber ich,
ich hätt Bock,
das auszuprobieren.
Ja.
Also,
dann flashen,
dann flash-champen wir mal wieder
ein paar Steckdosen.
Aber schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Wie gesagt,
eine,
eine hab ich zusammen,
hab ich auseinander gebaut
und die sah halt wirklich ganz genau so aus,
ja,
also,
es ist,
es ist wirklich so,
außer,
dass ich hier oben Debug-Anschlüsse hab
und er nicht.
Oder wie nennt man das?
Nicht Debug-Anschlüsse,
also Pins,
ja,
doch Debug-Anschlüsse.
Das haben die China-Chinesen
das Ganze schon mal
bisschen ordentlicher gemacht.
Ja,
schade,
dass es nicht OTA-Flashbar ist.
Oder ich hab's nicht richtig ausprobiert,
das können wir nachher ja auch mal ausprobieren.
Vielleicht hab ich,
manchmal muss man das OTA-Flashen
ja drei, vier Mal probieren,
bis es funktioniert.
Naja.
Aber,
nur so das am Rande.
Ja,
mir fällt immer noch nicht ein,
was ich ursprünglich erzählen wollte.
Lul.
Lasst uns mal einen
Blick in die GitHub-Trends
dieser Woche werfen.
Lasst mich raten.
AI,
AI
und bisschen Krypto-Shit.
AI,
ja, geht schon los.
nee,
ähm,
HTMLX,
AI,
Comfy UI,
was sonst?
A server software re-implementation
for a certain anime game.
Ist das,
ist das nicht,
ist das nicht dieses,
dieses Genshin Impact Projekt hier?
Wo sie nicht,
wo sie nicht erwähnen dürfen,
dass es
damit zu tun hat?
Oh,
nicht so spannend heute.
Ja,
das ist halt,
seit Monaten nur AI.
Das hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Wobei je nachdem,
wo man guckt,
also wenn man jetzt mal explizit zum Beispiel zu JavaScript gehen,
da gibt's tatsächlich wieder die,
die 0815 JavaScript Libraries.
Hier, guckt euch,
guckt euch das an.
HTMLX gibt's jetzt,
die HTMX High Power Tools for HTML.
Es, wie gesagt,
es vergehen keine drei Tage für neue JavaScript,
wobei eigentlich eher drei JavaScript Frameworks an einem,
noch seit einem Tag.
Fireship Video,
das haben wir sogar,
glaube ich,
noch irgendwo offen.
Vielleicht guckt man das gleich.
Oh,
nicht so spannend.
Nicht so spannend.
Wir haben das Fireship Video irgendwo offen.
Das Ding ist,
keine Ahnung,
ich habe zu viel,
ich habe zu viel Tabs auf.
Ja,
ja,
HTMLX.
So,
Chatgame.
Habe ich die Woche irgendwas verpasst bei euch?
Gab's irgendwas Spannendes?
Ich meine, ich war fast jeden Tag on, außer gestern.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie es HTMLX und nicht HTMLX genannt haben.
Moin.
Aber irgendwas Spannendes.
Heiße hatte mal irgendwer...
Ach so, ja, eine, eine...
Ach so, ich kann ja keine Twitter-Messages mehr von mir aufbauen,
weil man sich einloggen muss.
Das ist so ein abgrundtief dummer Change, Alter.
Das regt mich immer noch auf.
Ab jetzt nur noch 4-Tage-Woche.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen,
sehr,
sehr...
Nice.
Und natürlich,
easy.
Easy as fuck.
Nice.
So muss das sein.
Ich habe gehört,
ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit macht jetzt auch Teilzeit.
Wobei der, glaube ich, nur 90% Teilzeit macht.
Es werden immer mehr Leute.
Wir werden,
wir werden immer mehr.
Zurecht.
Ja.
Wenn man genug Geld verdient,
wenn man genug Geld verdient,
dass man gut auskommt,
auch mit 4 Tagen,
warum sollte man 5 Tage arbeiten?
Ganz simple,
ganz simple Geschichte, oder?
Ganz simple Geschichte, oder?
Zumal man dann mehr Zeit hat,
zumal man dann mehr Zeit hat,
sich um seine eigenen Sachen zu kümmern.
Und ich ja mit dem anderen Krempel
auch noch nebenbei ein paar,
den ein oder anderen Euro verdienen kann.
Also insofern.
Also für mich ist es nach wie vor
das Beste, was es gibt,
Hendrik Nikkel
Es war sehr schön,
es war ein ultrasound by Hard molto
Es war ein ultrasound by Hard molto
von registrierten Werke
von registrierten Werken
bei der sadistischen
Dem cigar bonanza
Fidel,
Aber wen juckt's
Und dann machen wir noch Karaoke
Alter Leute, was ist mit euch los
16 Uhr hau ich ab, geh ich heim
Wenn ich nichts mehr mit der Arbeit zu tun hab
Sei denn nicht wer für bezahlt
Was bei uns hat man jetzt
Eine 39 Stunden Woche eingeführt
Es gibt aber erstmal für ein Jahr
39,5 und erst
Ja, dann solltest du es auch nicht
39 Stunden nennen, das ist geil, ne
Leute, wir führen eine 39 Stunden
Woche ein, aber es sind
39,5
Aber wir nennen es schon mal 39 Stunden Woche
Weil unser Ziel wird ja sein, dass es 39 wird
Also so Marketing, bla bla
Oh man
39 Stunden am Tag, jede Woche
Korrekt, so muss das sein
Die haben den 40 Stunden Tag erfunden
Du kannst ja eine Stunde hast
Zum Schlafen und deine Sachen zu machen, das reicht
Dann geht's weiter
Ich hab eine 30 Stunden Woche
Und das hilft auch enorm
Auch wenn der Freitag kurz ist, hilft er auch enorm
Ja
Also eine Sache, die mich ja wieder hat
An der aktuellen
Kurz zu heißen, weil ich kann ja
Mein eigenes Twitter nicht mehr aufmachen
Eine Sache, die mich auch etwas
Was ist das hier
Windows Schrift Renderer, ja
ClearType hat schon immer gesagt
Ja, also eine Sache, die mich auch wieder
Extrem verwirrt hat
Im aktuellen
Wie man sich sowas überhaupt kaufen kann
Ist folgendes
Wie heißt die, wie heißt die
Funmove oder so
Genau, also
Es gibt einen niederländischen
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal bei dem Namen
Also es gibt einen
E-Bike Hersteller
Der hat seine E-Bikes gekoppelt
Mit einer Smartphone App
Das ist ja an sich
Nicht so wild, das kann man ja machen
Weil das über Bluetooth kommuniziert
Aber
Wenn man über Bluetooth direkt mit dem Fahrrad kommunizieren kann
Muss vorher eine Verbindung zu den Cloud-Servern hergestellt werden des Herstellers
So
Das allein ist natürlich schon etwas
Fragwürdig vielleicht
Aber fragt man sich, was kann da schon schief gehen
Ja
Das Problem ist jetzt
Dass der Hersteller wohl eventuell demnächst Pleite geht
Oder demnächst dicht macht, die Server schließt, was auch immer
Und dann können die Leute
Die App nicht mehr richtig verwenden mit ihrem Fahrrad
Und dann können die Leute die App nicht mehr richtig verwenden mit ihrem Fahrrad
Und dann können die Leute
Die App nicht mehr richtig verwenden mit ihrem Fahrrad
Und wir reden hier jetzt nicht etwa damit
Dass du da irgendwelche komischen
Dinger machen kannst
socially
Die zutre terug
convex
Also du kannst das Licht an deinem Fahrrad nicht mehr ordentlich benutzen
Von der Cloud
Ja
Jeden Tag
Und die haben finanzielle Probleme
sie die server die serverdicht hier in diesem fall würde die app nicht mehr funktionen und
e-bikes wichtige funktion verlieren für dieses szenario moment wo steht das mit dem licht habe
ich das habe ich das bei golem gelesen irgendwo ja genau die app der app betrieb ist allerdings
voraussetzung für wichtige features wie die steuerung von licht und geschwindigkeit also
wer auf die bescheuerte idee gekommen ist dass du ein fahrrad nur noch mit cloud anbindung richtig
verwenden kannst der gehört echt geschlagen ich bin nicht für körperliche gewalt normalerweise
aber in dem fall würde ich meine ausnahme machen ich finde ich finde an sich dass durchaus in
ordnung dass das ding über bluetooth lokal mit dem fahrrad kommuniziert aber das ist vorher erst
einmal eine cloud verbindung braucht ist halt auch schon pp gas und warum ist das warum ist
das weil die hersteller alle möglich als sie werden das mit security begründen oder mit mit
irgendwelchen anderen fadenscheinigen sachen warum ist das weil die hersteller sich alle
lockt innen wollen in ihr ökosystem und ihren kram selbst wenn es zum aktuellen zeitpunkt gar
keinen sinn macht die denken sich wir machen erstmal vendor login vielleicht machen wir
dann in zukunft noch mehr damit ja vielleicht haben wir dann demnächst noch fragt mich nicht
ein skateboard oder so was man nur damit pären kann oder irgendwelche zusatz gadgets und und
hast du nicht gesehen er erst mal wird wird lockt und dann wird sich überlegt was was machen wir
jetzt eigentlich damit und das hier sieht man mal wieder die idee dass ein fahrrad nur mit cloud
anbindung gescheit funktioniert und dann wird sich überlegt was machen wir jetzt eigentlich damit und
das hier sieht man mal wieder die idee dass ein fahrrad nur mit cloud anbindung gescheit funktioniert
ist halt nicht so schlau echt es gibt mittlerweile maus hersteller wo du die maus registrieren muss
cloud sachen benutzen muss dass sie überhaupt funktioniert das ist mir jetzt neu also was mich
ja persönlich schon immer richtig nervt ist bei nvidia die geschichte wurde jetzt neuerdings dass
du diese diesen nvidia geforce wie nennt sich dieses ding hier die geforce x ne ne nicht das
hier das ist ja der normale treiber die geforce experience halt das ist ja der normale treiber
ist und die diesen tool integration fun workloads man kann eigentlich auch von einen sehr längeren
die experience dabei ist dass du neuerdings ein account brauchst aber neuerdings ist gut du
brauchst die letzten sieben jahre oder so schon ein account aber es geht früh error Text
anbieter wo ich höre meine Kerne der App darüber ich frage mich halt immer noch warum braucht eine
software wo ich lokal bspw videos capturen kann und grafikkarten treiber-update machen kann warum
brauchten sie zwangsläufig ein nvidia account man kann bilder hoch laden und so was ja das ist okay
Aber wenn ich Bilder hochladen will zum Sharen, dann kann ich über diese Software, da kann ich mir immer noch einen Nvidia-Account machen.
Da brauche ich nicht standardmäßig, da muss ich nicht gezwungen werden dazu, einen Nvidia-Account zu machen.
Äh, total, total bescheuert.
Und in dem Fall hat es die hier halt erwischt jetzt, wenn die die Server zumachen von dem Fahrradanbieter,
dann geht halt die App nicht mehr und du kannst dein Licht und die Geschwindigkeit vom E-Fahrrad nicht mehr einstellen.
Das ist wirklich maximal hängen geblieben.
Mal gucken, was das Heise-Forum dazu sagt.
Und das Heise-Forum ist am Circle-Jerken über die App, gehe ich mal von aus.
Hat sich ausgehipstert, ja, wenn ich das schreibe.
Heise-Forum ist wieder am Start.
Die wollen gerne E-Mail-Adressen sammeln.
Ja, ja, mir ist schon klar, warum die das machen, aber aus Kundensicht und Funktionssicht ist es halt total dämlich.
Man braucht gar keinen Account dafür, um lokal E-Mails, äh, lokal E-Mails, um lokal Videos aufzunehmen
und...
und Screenshots zu machen und Grafikkartentreiber abzudaten.
Es würde reichen, wenn ich Bilder hochladen will, wenn man dann einen Account braucht.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist das, was ich gerade erzählt habe.
Wir machen erstmal irgendwelche Vendor-gebundenen oder Hersteller-gebundenen Sachen
und dann überlegen sie sich, was könnte man damit machen und die haben halt gelitten mit dem Fahrrad.
Das ist aber schwierig, du kannst das Unternehmen nicht dazu zwingen, das zu machen.
Also an sich, an sich schon wahrscheinlich gesetzesmäßig gibt es das nicht her.
Und das Zweite...
Das Zweite ist, ein Unternehmen, was kurz vor der Pleite ist, lässt sich eh schwierig mit irgendwelchen Sachen zu irgendwas zwingen.
Weil die sagen sich, ey, wir sind eh pleite und das Einzige, was ihr machen würdet, ist es vielleicht noch ein bisschen zu beschleunigen.
Das kannst du, das kannst du vergessen.
Aber, achso, ja, eine Sache, falls jemand, äh, was hat...
Ähm, hier, eine Sache ist tatsächlich noch ganz gut, was, was auch in dem Artikel irgendwo drin stand.
Es gibt auf GitHub ein...
...Exporter für den Encryption-Key, dass man keine Cloud mehr braucht.
Dann gibt es quasi Custom...
Weiß nicht, ob man Custom-Firmware flashen muss auf das Fahrrad.
Großartig hat das hochgeladen.
Groß...
Großartig.io
Trau ich mich, das aufzumachen?
Die...
Der Name klingt gut.
Den finde ich, finde ich nice.
Ich, ich trau mich, ich trau mich, das aufzumachen.
Großartig.io
Ich finde, das ist eine richtig, eine richtig gute Domain.
Oh, das sieht...
...nach Web 5.0 Webseite aus.
Guck mal.
Sogar die, sogar die Partikel im Hintergrund bewegen sich, wenn man die Maus...
Seht ihr das?
Richtig krasse Hipster-Webseite.
So.
Aber sieht auch ganz stylish aus.
Because change needs a secure environment.
Ach, das ist ein...
Das ist ein WordPress oder...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Okay, ich weiß nicht.
Aber großartig hat das anscheinend großartigerweise programmiert.
Da kann man die Keys von seinem E-Bike extrahieren.
Und dann...
...ist irgendwie auch ohne App benutzen.
Das Problem dabei ist, dass das halt den 0815 E-Bike-User komplett überfordert.
Sag doch mal irgendeinem Typ, der sich...
...sag doch mal einem Typ, der sich ein E-Bike gekauft hat, aber jetzt nicht so Computer- und Technik-affin ist.
Sag dem mal, okay, anstatt einfach die Smartphone-App zu benutzen, gehst du mal vorher auf GitHub.
Dann lädst du dir den FunMove Encryption...
...Key-Export herunter.
Dann installierst du die Docker und startest es im Docker-Container.
Dann machst du den Browser auf, gehst dahin, verbindest das dann mit Bluetooth mit deinem Fahrrad.
Da denken die sich dann auch, keck, wait, was will der Kerl von mir?
Optional Use Reverse Proxy.
Ja, ja, ist alles klar.
NPM Run, NPM Build.
Das macht natürlich der 0815 nicht, sondern die Technikinteressierte.
Aber trotzdem ist es super, dass es sowas gibt.
Die Playlist.
Die Playlist ist unterschiedlich laut.
Alternativ hat jetzt irgendein Konkurrenthersteller was dazu angeboten.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist the way to go, wenn man so einen E-Bike hat.
Und dass man unabhängig wird von irgendwelchen komischen Kack-Cloud-Anbindungen und sonstige Geschichten.
War das eigentlich nicht dieser Fahrradhersteller, der dir ein neues Fahrrad zur Verfügung stellt, wenn das...
Keine Ahnung, ich habe mich nie mit beschäftigt.
Das klingt an sich schon bescheuert, den Key von meinem E-Bike-Export.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen, keck, geh, da hast du recht.
Leute, ich habe noch ein paar 7TV-Emotes hinzugefügt.
Ich glaube, ich muss jetzt auch mal mehr 7TV-Emotes benutzen.
Weil eh mittlerweile jede Extension die Emotes der jeweils anderen unterstützt.
Also FFZ kann 7TV, Better Twitch TV und FFZ.
Better Twitch TV kann FFZ, Better Twitch TV.
Wahrscheinlich auch 7TV, 7TV kann auch sonst alles.
Und da kriegt man auch ein paar zusätzliche Emote-Slots.
Ich glaube sogar über 100 oder 500 oder so.
Unendlich, nahezu unendlich Emote-Slots.
Jo.
So, machen wir das mal wieder dicht hier.
Ach so.
Lass mich gerade nochmal kurz gucken, was der aktuelle Trend in der .NET-Welt ist.
Avalonia trendet.
Ja, haben wir uns letztens angeguckt.
Ich fand es nicht schlecht.
Wenn vielleicht auch noch die ein oder anderen Controls fehlen, zum Beispiel ein Webview wäre ganz cool.
Klar, man kann auch immer noch einen externen Browser öffnen, aber ein Webview wäre schon sehr nice.
Und nicht als Third-Party-Add-On.
Ich gette aber auch, dass die das nicht wollen, weil das ziemliche Abhängigkeiten mit sich zieht.
Nach sich zieht.
Ja.
Die wohl fehlen.
Die verbreitetste .NET-Library, um Sachen zu over-engineeren.
Maury trendet.
Das verstehe ich nicht, warum Maury trendet.
Ich mag Maury überhaupt nicht.
Terminal GUI.
Cross-Plattform Terminal UI Toolkit.
Okay, nice.
Was können die so?
Öh.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Endcurses.
So was.
Öh.
Okay, das ist quasi Endcurses für PowerShell oder sowas.
Für Windows.
Oder es ist Cross-Plattform.
Dann ist es Endcurses nachgebaut für alles andere als Windows.
Also für Windows, Mac, Linux.
Ja, gut.
Warum nicht, wenn man sowas mag?
Ich mag so Terminal-UIs nicht.
Ich mag CLI-Tools, die man ordentlich benutzen kann, aber keine Terminal-UIs.
Unity-Zeug.
Machine Learning Unity.
Blazer-Gedöns.
Message-Bus.
China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Keine Ahnung.
Leaky Office Tools.
Und Revoke Message Pager.
Ah, ein Hex-Editor für WeChat.
Okay, das ist China-Chinesen-Zeug-Deluxe.
Tochen-Tracker, die wir selbstverständlich alle nur benutzen, um Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen.
Obviously.
entitled-avelonia.examples space-station-14
Okay, Leute, wenn ihr ein Game macht, wäre halt Screenshots extrem, Porg.
Was ist das?
Spacestation 14?
Wie war es von gehört?
Garten-Krade.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, dann haben wir einen Discord-Chat-Exporter.
Okay, das klingt nach einem sinnvollen Tool.
Man kann Chatlogs exportieren.
exportieren aus Discord in den File.
Wer weiß, ob man
in der Chat irgendwie verschwinden, Discord irgendwann mal was löscht.
Auch zum besser
durchsuchen und alles. Das finde ich tatsächlich mal
eine sehr sinnvolle Geschichte.
Wie benutzt man das? Wie benutzt man das
ordentlich?
Also was?
Wie?
Maintenance Mode, okay.
Wie benutzt man das richtig?
Wie funktioniert das?
Aber man muss irgendein
Discord-Authentifizierungstoken
oder so reinbauen.
Naja, gut.
Vielleicht braucht man das mal.
Bitworn Mobile App.
Fast Shithub.
Für die China-Chinesen.
Poly, Poly ist nice.
Das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal verwendet.
PowerTools.
Ja, okay.
Ich finde ja immer gut, wenn man sich die C-Sharpen
und .NET-Trends anguckt, dass es nicht zu 90%
Machine Learning ist.
Weil ansonsten sind die GitHub-Trends
Machine Learning, AI, AI,
Machine Learning, Machine Learning, AI.
Bisschen Krypto-Zeug manchmal.
AI.
Windows finally gets native
RAR-Support. In der heutigen
Zeit, wo kaum noch eine RAR verwendet wird.
Leute, wann habt ihr das letzte Mal ein RAR-Archiv
gebraucht?
Erzählt mal.
Also ich vermute mal,
dass es bei mir noch nicht ganz so lange hier ist.
Weil ich mir letztens ein paar Sachen
von Archive,
.org, runtergeladen habe.
Und da waren Sachen
in RAR drin. Also vielleicht
zwei, drei Monate her.
Aber insgesamt ist RAR-Archive schon recht
RAR, ja.
Usenet. Ah, das ist bestimmt
auch noch für Linux-Distributionen, oder?
Zip. Ja, ganz ehrlich.
Es ist immer noch 95%, dass es
eine Zip-Datei ist. Deswegen ist es auch
richtig gut, dass Google jetzt als
Top-Level-Domain .zip hat.
Um noch mehr die Leute zu scammen.
Winnera. Beste Anschaffung.
Der Kauf hat sich.
Nicht gelohnt. Naja.
Das ist eine Software, die hätte man sich
vor 20 Jahren kaufen können und heute immer noch benutzen.
Ich weiß nicht, wann gab es denn
WinRAR Version History?
Wann gab es denn da die letzte Version von?
Moment, was?
Vor zwei Monaten?
Ich hätte
jetzt gedacht, die letzte WinRAR-Version
ist von
von sonst wann
Uhrzeiten.
Guck mal hier.
Ja.
Das wird sogar noch regelmäßig.
Okay, man muss
sagen, seit 2013 ist
ein bisschen weniger passiert.
Da sind immer ein paar Jahre dazwischen.
Das wäre praktisch
gewesen.
Da habe ich tatsächlich mehr als RAR-Files
written in C++.
Das wundert mich nicht zur damaligen Zeit.
WinRAR.
Kennt noch jemand von euch?
WinAce.
Das erste, was du
über Kugel findest,
ist WinAce-Serial-Key.
Geil, das filtert gut.
Google macht sich halt immer Mühe,
das irgendwie rauszufiltern.
Kennt dieses Ding noch jemand?
Das war...
Ich weiß nicht, ob Wikipedia überhaupt
einen Eintrag hat.
Das war zu Zeiten, als man sich noch
Sicherheitskopien aus dem Internet runtergeladen hat
vor 15 bis 20 Jahren.
Sehr anges...
Sag mal vor...
Sagen wir vor...
Vor 20 bis 25 Jahren
war das sehr angesagt
als WinRAR-Alternative.
Und das letzte
Stable-Release ist da allerdings
schon 2007 gewesen.
Das wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt.
Okay.
WinAce.
Nur Sicherheitskopien.
Immer.
Ich habe nie was anderes als Sicherheitskopien
runtergeladen.
Das sieht ein bisschen so aus,
aber ich meinte die Windows-Version davon.
WinAce.
Also,
YouTube ist ganz...
ganz der Meinung,
wir müssen das hier angucken,
aber das interessiert mich nicht.
Das gibt einen Trick.
Wenn man bei YouTube das Video anklickt
und gleich wieder schließt,
dann sollte YouTube checken,
dass man das nicht sehen will.
Haben wir noch Tabs?
Ja, ja, gibt noch ein paar.
Guck da.
Ich habe noch welche.
Ups.
Remove.
Es sind noch nicht alle Tabs leer.
Ich kann noch welche aufmachen.
Und ich habe ja auch genug RAM.
Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es überhaupt ein Limit gibt.
Also, aktuell habe ich ja noch viel zu viel RAM frei.
Guck mal.
10 GB von 64.
Das ist ja nix.
Da müssen wir...
Sekunde, Leute.
Ich muss mal in den VM starten.
Bisschen RAM.
Ihr wisst doch,
wie das unter Linux so ist.
Und unter Windows gilt das Gleiche.
Nicht benutzter RAM ist verschenkter RAM.
Man kann auch rechtsklick kein Interesse wählen.
Nee, kann man nicht.
Weil das geht nur,
wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Unused Tabs werden einfach gefreezed.
Oh, das ist aber...
Das ist aber sadke.
Ich wollte eigentlich meinen RAM
ordentlich benutzen,
Oh, guck mal.
Es gibt eine neue Go-Version.
Was gibt es denn Neues in Go?
Go-Release.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Release History.
Es gibt ein neues Go-Release.
Und zwar wann?
Äh.
Nee, irgendein Miner-Release,
was nicht weiter juckt.
Oh, dann...
Das ist ja langweilig.
Machen wir mal kurz Update.
Dann starte ich die VM neu.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Was zum Teufel?
NWG Look.
Shedkill.
Was habe ich da installiert?
NWG Look.
GitHub.
Was ist das?
Ah, GTK Settings und sowas.
Okay.
Es hat bestimmt seinen Grund,
warum ich NWG Look
versus LX Appearance genommen habe.
Wahrscheinlich, weil LX Appearance
irgendwie nicht richtig...
Ah ja, ich weiß warum.
Weil LX Appearance den Mauszeiger
nicht ändern konnte,
aber NWG Look schon.
Ja, wir haben ab und zu schon
die ein oder anderen Videos von ihm geguckt.
Aber es ist nicht so,
als würde ich jetzt da jedes Video verfolgen.
Wir hatten es ja letztens davon,
welche deutschsprachigen IT-Channels
ich gucke.
Und ich muss sagen,
ich bin immer noch der Meinung,
dass Algorithmen verstehen,
beziehungsweise der Florian,
dass das der beste Channel ist
im deutschsprachigen Raum.
Allerdings sind halt auch viele Videos
sehr spezifisch, wo ich sagen muss,
gut, da interessiert mich das Thema dahinter halt nicht.
Aber wenn ich eins gucke, finde ich,
sind das mit Abstand die besten Videos.
Morpheus gucke ich auch ab und zu noch,
wenn es ein Thema ist,
was mich interessiert.
Aber ansonsten,
ich will da jetzt keinem Unrecht tun,
den ich vielleicht vergesse.
Ich gucke bestimmt die ein oder anderen Videos sonst noch.
Von, von,
wie heißt der,
Kevin Chromic,
oder so gibt es noch.
Von dem haben wir auch ein paar geguckt.
Ich weiß leider nicht genau, wie er heißt.
Ich lasse es mit Aussprache.
Ich habe es mir nicht gemerkt.
Von dem haben wir auch ein paar Videos letztens geguckt.
Äh, wo er aus, aus Spanien Homeoffice gemacht hat.
Native Web, Native Web ist auch Porc.
Native Web gucke ich immer gerne.
Ja, ja, das stimmt.
Wobei ich das, das,
nicht, nicht, nicht so wirklich dazu zählen würde.
Die anderen machen ja auch so ein bisschen,
ja, so ein IT-Lifestyle,
kann man das so nennen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Die erzählen dann auch mal,
okay, wie ist das so,
äh, Homeoffice aus Spanien zu arbeiten,
oder beste Entscheidungen,
in meinem Job, und sowas.
Und Native Web macht halt wirklich immer nur ganz,
ja, fachlich bezogene, gut gemachte,
meistens Frontend bezogene,
Technikvideos.
Aber die gucke ich gerne an, ja.
Hacken mit Chat-GPT, Alter, jetzt übertreibt es halt.
Ich habe keinen Bock auf die ganzen AI-Videos mehr.
Mir reicht es irgendwann.
Ich, ich bin, ich bin wirklich komplett gesättigt,
was AI-Videos angeht.
Weiß nicht, wie, wie es euch geht, aber ich,
ich gucke mir vielleicht in der Woche noch zwei Videos an zu dem Thema.
Aber das war's.
Rest, Rest, ist, das, das meiste ist auch einfach nichts Neues,
sondern nur quasi so, so Re, Rehash von den Videos,
wie es sich schon gegeben hat.
Hat er mal vielleicht wieder ein, ein,
Tieren-Menschen-Automation oder sowas?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Okay, Chat, wollen wir anfangen, uns ein paar Videos reinzuhauen?
Gab's die Woche noch,
oder, im Moment haben wir noch drei, vier, fünf, zehn Videos,
oder, haben wir noch drei, fünf, sechs Videos?
Wir wissen nur noch, wie lang die Zeit ist,
wie lange ist eine Woche da und wann ein Video kommt.
Und wenn du nach einem Video kommen willst,
um ein Video zu gehen, dann musst du mal mal mehr auf Instagram gehen.
Wir sehen uns wieder, bis dann.
Es gibt noch ein paar Videos, die wir noch machen können,
wo wir ein Video machen.
Aber am besten noch ein Video,
wo wir noch einちゃtes Video machen wollen.
Da werden wir noch ein paar Videos machen,
wo wir ein paar Videos machen wollen,
und dann wird es ein bisschen komisch,
weil hier ist uns noch ein Video für euch.
Wir haben noch ein paar Videos,
aber wir werden es auch zum nächsten Mal machen.
Bis dann, tschüss.
Bye, bye.
ist ja teilweise sogar direkt windows integriert wpf aber nicht ja das ist so wie wenn du wpf
benutzt wenn du wenn du wpf benutzt dann ist es ja auch die ui technologie gut du kannst das ist
ein doofes beispiel weil du kannst sie nur unter windows laufen lassen aber sagen wir du hast du
anwendungen avalon ja gemacht dann brauchst du logischerweise auch avalon ja nicht nicht
installiert aber halt für deine für dein programm um es zu kompilieren was war das fazit von dem
diesjährigen primeday ich glaube ich habe irgendwie 300 euro oder so ausgegeben und
wahrscheinlich ein paar ganz günstige sinnvolle sachen gefunden der anderen seite allerdings auch
wieder nicht so toll weil wahrscheinlich werde ich liga nicht brauchen ja ich habe mir den super
billigen pack fleischbare steckdosen also wahrscheinlich fleischbare steckdosen leisten
wieder gekauft ein heizungs thermostat und so was einfach zum basteln nicht weil ich wirklich
brauche ich glaube ich glaube das einzig wirklich sinnvolle was ich mir gekauft habe ist eine bosch
professional tape measure
also so ein maß band sondern so ein teil zum zum ausziehen ist ja da habe ich nur ein billiges
ikea de oder wollte ich schon länger längst länger längere zeit mal gescheit das ja und dann unter
neue sich bistig den werde ich auch benutzen hast du schon mal mit elastisch gearbeitet ja
habe ich wir hatten auf der alten arbeit wir hatten auf der alten arbeit ein elastisch cluster für logs
system logs als auch anwendungs logs und ich bin mir aber gar nicht mehr sicher was da alles noch
oben da war dann wie nennt sich das elk oder elks deck ist das nicht so loks dash ja genau ja ja
ja ich erinnere mich elastik hibana genau ja ja ja dass die kombination hatten wir elastik
search loks dash hibana der elks deck feil biet feil biet hatten wir auch ja genau genau
genau ich erinnere mich das ding ist aber ich habe damals nicht viel damit gemacht also ich
weiß dass wir weil man die musik ist viel zu laut warum anzeige aber ich habe damit nicht
viel gemacht das einzige was ich bei uns bei elastik soll es mitbekommen habe ist dass der
elastic search support kacke ist wir hatten ein paar mal
das programs im kurs verpasst und dann sind wir verwandt und haben dann das lg abgehakt
das Problem, dass unser Cluster irgendwie keine neuen
Nodes mehr aufnehmen konnte und
der Elasticsearch-Cluster
irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
sich auf jeden Fall auch nicht
mit Ruhm bekleckert hat.
Und es ewig, teilweise Wochen gedauert hat, bis sich
da irgendwas getan hat.
Wie ist eure Erfahrung mit Elasticsearch?
Oder fragst du jetzt für den Fall der Fälle,
weil du es einsetzen willst
und nicht genau sicher bist?
Also, das Einzige, was ich
von Elasticsearch wirklich noch im Hinterkopf habe,
ist, dass es ein ziemlich komplexes Setup ist.
Ich habe, wie gesagt,
ich habe es nicht selbst installiert, ich habe es auch nicht selbst
administriert und betrieben, nur so vom Beobachten.
Das es wohl ein sehr komplexes
Setup sein muss und
wo man sich wirklich fragen muss, ob sich
das echt lohnt.
Gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon ein paar Alternativen.
Also, ich weiß, dass beispielsweise
von den
Grafana-Leuten, gibt es ja
Loki und Bromtail, heißt das
glaube ich, für Logs.
Das ist natürlich nicht mit einem
vollwertigen Elasticsearch zu vergleichen.
Sag ich jetzt mal, ohne dass ich jetzt
direkt einen Vergleich machen könnte.
Aber wenn Logs das, wenn Log
einsammeln, das ist, was du machen willst, dann ist vielleicht
das die simplere Alternative.
Und was gibt es denn sonst noch?
Was gibt es denn sonst noch für...
Gibt es ja so zwei, drei größere Sachen
für Log und
Fulltextsearch und sowas. Was gibt es denn
sonst noch? Splunk gibt es noch? Ja, genau.
Craylock? Ja.
Sagt mir vom Namen her auch was.
Also, Splunk kenne ich.
Wo ich jetzt aktuell arbeite, haben die das.
Ich muss sagen, sonderlich
gefeiert habe ich die Software bis jetzt aber noch nicht.
Grepp ist immer noch die beste
Log-Auswertung. Gut, ich gebe
zu, der Vergleich hinkt. Es geht nicht
über mehrere Rechner, es geht auch nicht
über Terabyte-weise Dateien
gescheit und
Kontext aus den Logs
kannst du da auch nicht erkennen.
Aber trotzdem, auf die Schnelle
ist Grepp immer noch das Beste.
Oder Catgepiped in Grepp.
Auch wenn dann die ganzen
Linux-Handwerker
Hardcore-Leute wieder ankommen und sagen
Useless Use of Cat, aber
manchmal baut man sich halt
seine Befehle so zusammen.
Also, das ist ganz, ganz böse. Also, wenn ihr mal irgendwie
so einen richtigen Linux
Hardcore-Fanatiker triggern
wollt, dann macht ihr
sowas hier. Catplup.keckel
grepp nach
1 zum Beispiel.
Dann wird ihr euch sagen
Ha, lull, was ist hier los?
Useless Use of Cat.
Macht doch so, das geht doch auch.
Aber oftmals baut man sich ja
seine Befehle so zusammen und dann ist es
einfach einfacher, anstatt es dann eine halbe
Stunde rum zu editieren.
Vielleicht soll ich die Datei mal wieder löschen, dann habe ich
wieder so viele sinnlose Dateien rumliegen.
Habe ich eigentlich schon rebooted
jetzt nach dem Update?
Hat er alles geupdatet?
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nicht rebooted.
Da können wir mal kurz den PepoHappy-Background
bestaunen gleich. Also,
grepp-l, also groß L
kriege ich nicht zusammen, was das heißt.
Case insensitive und minus R ist recursive auf
das komplette Dateisystem.
Pog?
Ne, nicht Pog.
Okay.
Exzellenter Hintergrund.
Pepo ist gerade am Essen.
Ich trinke auch mal was.
L-Liste Datei
mit minus groß L ohne
äh
Achso.
Ja, was macht minus groß L?
Ohne den Pfad oder was?
Ach, nur den Pfad.
Ich habe gestern erst mal Standing Desk
zu Hause aufgebaut. Beste.
Also, du hast wahrscheinlich einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch.
Nicht extra einen, wo man nur
standen kann. Ich habe ja auch einen
höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch. Ich muss sagen,
ich verwende das Stehen
weniger
als ich sollte. Obwohl ich
alles extra so vom Setup gebaut habe,
dass die Kabel lang genug
sind und sowas. Und ich könnte, ich habe
hier sogar hier neben am Tisch das Ding liegen
zum Runterfahren.
Aber
ich bin zu faul.
Mit der Kurbel.
Aber mit der Kurbel hätte ich noch weniger
Bock gehabt. Hätte ich noch weniger
Bock gehabt. So machen.
Exzellente Backgrounds.
Übrigens, wenn euch die Hintergründe
gefallen, ne, die gibt's
auf GitHub.
Pepo.
White Pepo Happy Background.
Da habt ihr die ganzen
Bilder. Und es gibt
einen Pepo, die hat der Ragman
gebaut hier.
Da, hier, Kredits.
Es gibt einen Pepo für jede
Tageszeit, ja. Mittagessen Pepo.
Kekses Pepo. Arbeits
Pepo. Energy Booster
Pepo. Äh, Hintergrund, um
weitere Hintergründe zu machen.
Frühstück, Frühstück, Tee
Pepo. Nur, oder Kaffee,
warmer Kaffee Pepo und
äh, Cornflake, ne, äh,
Dinger hier.
Haben wir das Ganze noch zum Sonnenaufgang.
Dann träumt
er von komischen Sachen.
Und schläft.
Und da geht die Sonne unter, da geht er
Zähneputzen und da guckt er YouTube.
Und da geht er ins Bett.
Ja, gut zu wissen.
Also, wenn ihr Ideen habt für noch mehr
Backgrounds, Leute,
dann schickt es am besten hier oder im
Discord an den Ragman, der macht das.
Dann haben wir noch mehr nice
Pepos, ich könnte auch noch ein paar mehr gebrauchen.
Ja, also.
Immer, immer nice.
Ja.
Das war mit dem Pepo. Ja, das war's. Danke fürs Zuschauen und bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Das war mit Fee. Ja, du kannst benutzen,
was du willst. Also, die Bilder sind ja
unabhängig von unserem komischen Backgrounds.
Set Backgrounds Skript.
Das musst du ja nicht verwenden. Du kannst die Bilder...
Man kann die übrigens auch unter Windows verwenden.
Man muss die nicht zwangsläufig mit unserem
Change Skript verwenden.
So sieht's aus.
Ah, ja.
Okay, dann
schauen wir uns mal auf YouTube um,
was wir uns da so geben können.
Warum ich gestern nicht on war?
Ja, und ganz kurz.
Ich hab
eine Runde
Jagged Alliance
3 gespielt.
Seit Jahren mal wieder
ein ganz gutes Game in dieser Serie.
Ja, eine kurze Runde.
Irgendwie 6 Stunden oder so am Stück.
Aber
es kommt für mich bis jetzt noch nicht
ganz an den zweiten Teil dran.
Der zweite Teil hatte einfach so viele
Pog-Sachen drin.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall
mal wieder ein ganz gutes
Taktik-Runden-basiertes Taktik-Game.
Ich spiele das heute immer noch ab und zu, ne?
Dance Wars Zombies ist...
Es ist so verkackt worden.
Ganz ehrlich. Der erste Teil war richtig gut.
Man hätte einen
mega geilen zweiten Teil machen können.
Was haben sie gemacht?
Ein Smartphone-only-Game mit Pay-to-Win-Mechanics.
Und das ist schon lange her.
Das heißt,
das kommt auch nicht mehr für eine andere Plattform.
Ja.
Und sie haben jetzt ja versucht, einen dritten Teil...
zu machen.
Und das ging halt komplett in die Hose.
Das ist halt so schlimm.
Der Plans Wars Zombies 3
und dieser Versuch,
was sie da versucht haben zu releasen,
ja,
das sieht schlechter aus
als der erste Teil.
Ihr müsst euch das mal vorstellen.
Das sieht einfach...
Das sieht einfach schlechter aus als der erste Teil.
Okay, es sieht jetzt schon mal besser aus
als ganz am Anfang.
Aber es hat überhaupt nicht mehr...
optisch überhaupt nicht mehr den Charme
von der Grafik des ersten Teils.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
wann das rauskommt.
Ich freue mich, dass es einen zweiten Teil gibt.
Alan Wake war jetzt ja,
sagen wir mal, nicht so die große Stärke,
das reine Gameplay.
Ich glaube, viele Leute haben das Spiel nie beendet,
weil ihnen so das Gameplay
an sich nicht gefallen hat.
Aber ich fand die Atmosphäre,
die Story,
das Storytelling und...
auch die Hintergrundgeschichte
und alles drumherum.
Ich fand Alan Wake extrem nice.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich mag auch die ganzen Remedy Games.
Was heißt die ganzen?
So viele haben die ja nicht gemacht.
Was haben die für Games gemacht?
Die haben Max Payne, Alan Wake,
Dingsbums hier, das mit dem Hobbit,
äh...
Quantum Break
hieß das, glaube ich.
Ähm...
Und dann haben sie letztens
dieses...
Control?
Ja, Control hieß das.
Control war das einzige Remedy Game,
was ich nicht durchgespielt habe.
Unterschiedlich.
Aber Penne oder...
Fuseli...
Fuseli, wie auch immer man die ausspricht.
Aber auch schon Spaghetti, alles mögliche.
Ja.
Also ich habe außer Control
habe ich alle Remedy Games gespielt.
Und ich fand die,
fand die alle ziemlich gut.
Also Control habe ich nicht durchgespielt.
Warum ist das Stream eigentlich 1080p,
48 FPS?
Weil es der beste Kompromiss ist
aus Bandbreite und Flüssigkeit.
Manche Leute gehen sogar so weit
und machen den Gameplay in 900p.
48 FPS.
Dann hast du...
quasi für die Einzelnen
noch bessere Kompr...
Also das Bild sieht einfach dann noch
ein bisschen schärfer aus.
Oder weniger...
weniger Kompressions-Artefakte.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
ich finde das eine gute Kombination.
Ja, genau.
Jetzt im Blastop-Betrieb
ist es eh vollkommen egal.
Ich muss übrigens gerade mal gucken,
ob ich...
Ja.
Ich habe die Bitrate wieder runter gemacht.
Weil wenn ich irgendwelche Gaming-Sachen mache,
dann mache ich ja hier hoch auf 7900.
So, aber das können wir uns
auch noch auf YouTube jetzt mal
zu Gemüte...
führen.
Also...
I hacked this firmware
and found something concerning.
Ey, wenn das nicht G-Badis,
der Titel...
I made a 32-Bit-Computer inside...
What?
Okay.
Das ist mir, glaube ich,
zu harte Kost am Anfang.
HTMX in 100.
Der heilige Retro-Gaming-Kral.
Okay, das können wir uns angucken.
Das ist davor.
Ich habe gar nicht richtig hingehört.
Ja.
Ist es.
Okay.
Dann hören wir uns das doch mal an.
Das ist Mister.
Ein Gerät...
Mister?
Das alte Rechner und Spielkonsolen
zu 100% exakt...
Na ja, alte Spielkonsolen wie die Wii
bestimmt nicht,
weil das der Wii-Sound
im Hintergrund war.
Nachbild.
Guck mal hier.
Das ist Mister.
Ein Gerät, das alte Rechner
und Spielkonsolen
zu 100% exakt nachbildet.
Super Nintendo, ja.
Super Nintendo dürfte wahrscheinlich
somit das höchste der Gefühle sein, oder?
Ich weiß nicht,
was ich sonst noch kann,
aber viel...
Also der Unterschied ist,
also ich kenne das Teil
so vom Lesen.
Ich habe keins, ja.
Wobei, ich labere gar nicht.
Wahrscheinlich erklärt das
direkt im Video.
Ich muss jetzt gar nichts erzählen.
Monopol, danke schön für den Sub.
Und...
der Gelegenheit,
gerade mal gucken,
dass ich nicht wieder
die Hälfte übersehen habe.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Das krasse ist,
das ist kein normaler Computer
oder es ist vielleicht
auch gar kein Computer,
sondern ein sogenanntes FPGA.
Größter Unterschied?
Anders als bei normaler Emulation
soll es viel weniger Lag geben,
also viel weniger Verzögerung.
Normaler Emulation soll es
viel weniger Lag geben,
also viel weniger Verzögerung
zwischen dem Drücken
eines Controller Buttons
und der Reaktion des Spiels.
Das werde ich gleich ausprobieren
im Vergleich mit der guten alten Emulation
auf einem Raspberry 4.
Dazu hatten wir schon mal Videos.
Und ich frage mich selbst,
merke ich den Unterschied?
Wir probieren das erst mal
mit Super Mario World aus
und ich bin selbst sehr gespannt,
ob sich der ganze Output
mit dem FPGA Zeug überhaupt lohnt.
Ich glaube,
ich predikte jetzt einfach mal,
was da rauskommt.
Ich gehe davon aus,
für Leute,
die es pur so nah wie möglich
am Original wollen,
ist diese FPGA-Geschichte nice.
Für alle anderen würde ich sagen,
ist ein Emulator,
eine Emulatorkiste
trotzdem das Bessere.
Einfach weil du mehr Plattformen
darauf abbilden kannst.
Und wahrscheinlich,
weil du schlicht und ergreifend
mehr Features hast drum herum.
Und die Ausgabe
auf dem modernen Bildschirm
vielleicht sogar einfacher ist
und besser funktioniert.
Wir haben auch noch Pascal am Start.
Der ist quasi ein Pro-Gamer.
Solange es nicht Hector Pascal ist.
Und spielt Fighting Games.
Das ist so jemand,
der sehr sensibel
auf solche Sachen reagiert.
Mal gucken, ob er das erkennt,
wenn ich es nicht erkenne.
Über das Technische weiß Dennis Bescheid.
Der hat den Mister nämlich
schon auf Herz und Nieren getestet
und wird mir das alles erklären.
So, jetzt aber direkt ausprobieren,
ob ich einen Unterschied merke.
Bleibt dran.
Oder Turbo Pascal.
Beckerin, liebe Internet-Surfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert
von Intel Vipro.
Wenn ihr jetzt denkt,
hä, ich kenne Intel Core,
Celeron, Pentium,
aber was...
Vipro, ist das nicht,
ist das nicht diese
Remote-Management-Geschichte
von Intel?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt
durcheinander?
Das ist Vipro,
da kann ich euch helfen.
Vipro ist eine Plattform
für Unternehmensrechner.
Okay, nein, ist es nicht.
Wie nennt sich das Ding von Intel,
diese Remote-Management-
Steuerungsgeschichte?
Die, die schon für viele
Sicherheitsprobleme gesorgt hat.
Nee, das heißt, glaube ich,
Intel Management Engine
oder sowas.
Da Intel Vipro draufsteht,
wisst ihr nicht nur,
dass da mehr als genug
Rechenleistung drin steckt,
sondern auch, dass ihr die Rechner
kaputtet, weil die User
beispielsweise kaputt treiben.
Erbung Ende.
Ich fange jetzt einfach mal an
zu spielen.
Also ich weiß wirklich nicht,
welches von den beiden
Super Mario World
Raspi ist und was.
Okay, links ist der Mister
und rechts ist der Raspberry Pi.
Ich glaube, im direkten Vergleich
erkennt man es wahrscheinlich ganz gut,
dass die Farben ein bisschen
unterschiedlich sind.
Ich glaube, da muss man sich jetzt
nicht keine Gedanken machen.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich weder
am Emulieren und nicht
am nicht Emulieren, sondern am Winkel,
wie die Monitore aufgenommen werden.
Mister, die Controller haben wir
natürlich über Kabel angeschlossen,
damit wir nicht noch zusätzliche
Verzögerung einbauen.
Also es fühlt sich extrem direkt an.
Wenn das der Raspi ist,
kann das eigentlich nicht
geschlagen werden, weil das
fühlt sich super direkt an.
Also da habe ich irgendwie
überhaupt nichts auszusetzen.
Dann probiere ich jetzt mal
das zweite Gerät aus.
Oha, gut, das fühlt sich
genauso direkt an.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen,
ich dachte jetzt schon,
wunderbar, es kommt.
Oha, ich merke sofort den Leck,
aber nein, es fühlt sich
genauso direkt an.
In dieser Overworld-Karte,
da leckt es aber auch
auf dem Super Nintendo selbst
ein bisschen, wenn du drückst.
Das fühlt sich genauso direkt an.
Hm, diese Animation,
diese Aufpixel-Animation,
die sah irgendwie falsch aus.
Also ich spüre zwar keine Latenz,
aber irgendwie wirkt das auf mich
eine Art und Weise ruckelig.
Doch, ganz klar.
Ja, nee, ich glaube,
das habe ich mir nur eingebildet.
Auch das Ruckeln sieht genauso aus.
Ja, ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
ich könnte jetzt nicht sagen,
das hat eine Verzögerung,
das hat keine Verzögerung.
Ich merke das nicht auf Anhieb.
Was ich jetzt mal probiere,
ist, dass ich hier super
gleichzeitig bei beiden Gamepads
den X-Knopf drücke,
um zu gucken,
ob ich das irgendwie erkenne.
Habt ihr eine Empfehlung
für einen SSH-Client
für Windows Multi-Tap Sessions?
Wie wäre es, wenn du einfach
das ganz normale
Windows-Terminal benutzt?
Weil Windows hat mittlerweile
einen SSH-Client dabei.
Du kannst einfach
das ganz normale
Windows-Terminal benutzen.
Hier.
Und dann sagst du
sshkeckel.com
und dann funktioniert das.
So hier.
Machst einen neuen Tab auf.
Und noch besser,
das Ganze natürlich mit WSL.
Nehmt das,
das ist mittlerweile bei Windows dabei.
Kann mehrere Tabs.
Und SSH ist auch dabei.
Also es gibt eigentlich gar kein,
du brauchst eigentlich gar nichts
zusätzliches mehr.
Finger weg.
PowerShell selbst sagt,
aber um einfach SSH einzutippen,
reicht es ja schon.
Bei beiden Gamepads
den X-Knopf zu drücken,
um zu gucken,
ob ich das irgendwie erkennen kann,
dass es da einen Unterschied gibt.
Ich habe keinen Unterschied gesehen.
Ja?
Doch.
Links war ein Ticken schneller.
Wobei es halt auch einfach sein kann,
dass er nicht exakt synchron gedrückt hat.
Also.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass es da eine Idee früher da war.
Ich würde dazu tendieren zu sagen,
dass das das FPGA ist
und das ist der Raspi.
Ich würde dann jetzt aber mal
an den Profi weitergeben.
Wie fühlt sich das an?
Erste Sekunde fühlt sich gut an.
Hast du schon mal gespielt?
Ich habe das schon 300 Mal durchgespielt.
Deswegen gucke ich gerade so,
was sind die Stellen,
die man eigentlich blind spielt.
Und klappt es,
wenn ich es blind spiele?
Trotzdem.
Und wenn es nicht klappt,
dann muss ja eine kleine Verzögerung sein,
weil an mir kann es nie liegen.
Ich verstehe.
Es fühlt sich richtig an.
Allerdings brauche ich jetzt den Vergleich.
Ja.
Hör mal auf, Leute,
mit Europa X-Term.
Grausam.
Das haben wir auf der Arbeit.
Ich mag das überhaupt nicht.
Das fühlt sich an
wie eine Software von 1998.
Der ist schneller.
Der ist direkter.
Das hätte ich auch schon gesagt.
Gerade wenn ich
hier mich so ganz schnell hin und her mal bewege,
das fühlt sich nicht an,
als würde er irgendwie hinterherziehen.
Aber es ist nicht so,
dass man denkt,
wow, was für ein krasser Unterschied.
Das ist komplett spielbar
und ohne Probleme.
Und du kannst dann deine coolen Tricks machen.
Ich glaube,
wenn es wirklich hart auf hart kommt,
dann würde ich mir jetzt diesen hier greifen.
Ja, ist ja auch meine These.
Okay, dann würde ich jetzt sagen,
dann lass uns mal auf Street Fighter 2.
Das ist ja auch so dein...
Ich spiele es gerne.
Gut, also dieses Spiel bringt mir jetzt,
also weil ich das letzte Mal
vor ungefähr 300 Jahren gespielt habe,
da kann ich...
Das fühlt sich für mich ganz normal an,
aber ich kann es nicht,
überhaupt nicht beurteilen.
Also du gewinnst schon mal damit.
Ich gewinn schon mal.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
hätte ich viel besser gewonnen,
hätte ich auf dem Gerät gespielt?
Ja, probier es aus.
Ich muss sagen,
das fühlt sich schon einiges knackiger an.
Ja?
Ja, ja, das ist wirklich...
Ja, aber das würdest du auch sagen,
das ist besser.
Ich würde sagen,
dass das nicht nur besser ist,
sondern schon auch definitiv besser.
Ich glaube,
ich hatte ein bisschen weniger Leben
beim anderen.
Ist das, glaube ich, ein Zeichen dafür.
Wir haben unsere Antwort jetzt eingeloggt.
Das ist der FPGA, der Mister.
Okay, es macht anscheinend echt einen Unterschied,
auch wenn es sehr subtil ist,
weil sonst hätten nicht beide richtig gelegen.
Also es muss wohl schon spürbar sein.
Und wisst ihr,
ich glaube, so richtig spürbar wäre das erst,
also wo du es sofort sagen könntest,
ist, wenn du jetzt, keine Ahnung,
zwei, drei Monate
oder ein paar Tage, sagen wir mal,
ein paar Tage hiermit gespielt hast
und dann...
schiebt dir einer so ein Ding unter.
Dann wirst du wahrscheinlich sofort sagen,
Moment, irgendwas ist heute laggy
und stimmt nicht richtig.
Das ist der Raspi.
Also ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
aber Pascal ist sich total sicher.
Und wenn das jetzt nicht der FPGA ist,
dann fällt das Video aus.
Dann weiß ich nicht,
warum wir dieses Video machen.
Okay.
Ta-ta-ta-ta.
Jetzt machen wir den großen Reveal.
Hier hinten nämlich extra alles versteckt.
Hier haben wir den Mister FPGA.
Der läuft auf dem.
Habt ihr richtig erkannt.
Und hier ist der Raspi 4.
Mit direkt habt ihr es schon echt gut beschrieben.
Es ist verzögerungsfrei.
Das kommt super direkt rüber.
Und bei dem Raspi 4 muss man schon sagen,
ich habe da auch so ein paar Spezialoptionen noch aktiviert.
Run Ahead heißt eine.
Ach, das ist aktiviert?
Ja, genau.
Das habe ich extra aktiviert.
Das wäre mein Joker,
den ich jetzt eigentlich aus der Tasche ziehen wollte.
Dass ich sage, ja, okay,
aber Raspis und schnellere Rechner
haben ja dieses Run Ahead Feature.
Mir ist es immer so müh aufgefallen,
dass es da noch so ein Ticken direkter ist.
Und aber hier ohne Run Ahead Funktion
war es vielleicht auch nochmal ein müh verzögerter.
Aber es waren jetzt keine weltengroßen Unterschiede.
Man muss schon sagen,
Software Emulation ist heutzutage wirklich schon sehr, sehr gut.
Und die Hardware Emulation.
Ja, gerade für den Super Nintendo.
Das dürfte ja eines der meist emulierten Konsolen überhaupt sein.
Von dem FPGA und von dem Mister Projekt.
Das setzt nochmal eine Schippe oben drauf.
Und wie gesagt,
die absoluten Profis,
die schwören da halt drauf.
Und wir haben es jetzt im Test ja auch gesehen.
Das ist halt einfach super direkt.
Bin leider jetzt ein bisschen sauer,
weil ich immer gedacht habe,
Raspi 4, geil,
kann ich alle alten Spiele noch spielen.
Jetzt muss ich die ganze Zeit dran denken,
wenn ich mit dem Raspi spiele.
Ah, es könnte noch besser sein,
wenn ich mir so blöden Mist verkaufe.
Das ist die psychologische Komponente.
Dafür hast du es auf dem Raspberry Pi
sicherlich tausendmal komfortabler,
weil da halt ein richtiges Linux drunter läuft
oder dem, worauf man das Ganze laufen lässt.
Du hast mehr Emulatoren zur Auswahl.
Wahrscheinlich auch generell mehr Features.
Das nervt mich jetzt.
Zum Beispiel beim NeoGeo Metal Slug.
Und da sind die Slowdowns
auf dem original NeoGeo.
Also das Spiel überfordert die Hardware ein bisschen
und die Slowdowns sind genau
an den exakt identischen Stellen bei Mista
wie bei der Original-Hardware.
Und auch bei den ganzen Arcade-Automaten und so.
Also das ist schon wirklich eine
fast hundertprozentige Reproduktion.
Du hast in diesem FPGA
hast du quasi 110.000 logische Einheiten,
die du programmieren kannst.
Und es gibt fast 40 Spiele.
Das sieht ein bisschen rudimentär
zusammengesteckt aus, das Ding, oder?
Also ich gehe davon aus,
dass man das nicht selbst bauen muss,
sondern dass man das so geliefert bekommt.
Aber irgendwie sieht es ein bisschen
zusammengebastelt aus.
Zehntausend logische Einheiten.
Guckt mal.
Hier hast du so ein komisches Modul drauf.
Was ist denn das denn für eine Batterie wahrscheinlich?
Sieht aus, als kommt da eine Batterie rein.
Das hier ist eventuell Speicher.
Keine Ahnung.
Das da ist ein Netzwerkanschluss vermutlich.
Oder USB.
Ne, das ist USB, das ist Netzwerk.
Die du programmieren kannst.
Fast 40 Spielkonsolen,
die jetzt schon abgebildet sind.
Mega Drive, Neo Geo und so weiter.
Dann gibt es fast 60 Heimcomputer.
Du kannst auch schon 4x86er
heutzutage emulieren.
Aber ich denke so Sachen wie,
also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
beim Super Nintendo ist da spätestens Schluss.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass beispielsweise die Playstation
oder der N64 da draufläuft.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dann doch
ein bisschen zu komplex für das Ding.
Ich habe jetzt Day of the Tentacle
da nochmal durchgespielt.
Das war sehr cool.
Lass uns doch einmal das Mr. Menü angucken.
Hier hast du die verschiedenen Cores.
Die sind sortiert nach Arcade, Computer, Konsole.
Wenn du hier reingehst, findest du dann
hier vom Atari 2600
über ein Gameboy.
Was auch ganz cool ist, die haben zum Beispiel
Gameboy Advance 2 Player.
Also das ist wie als würdest du dich mit einem Linkkabel verbinden.
Aber mit einem Splitscreen kannst du Gameboy gegeneinander spielen.
Es gibt Leute, die haben damals Pokémon getauscht
mit einem Linkkabel.
Super Nintendo natürlich, Super Gameboy.
Es ist vieles dabei.
Aktuell ist Ende der Fahnenstange Playstation 1.
Der Core ist so groß,
dass er den FPGA komplett
Ach PS1 geht doch.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Jetzt ist aber noch ein deutscher Entwickler,
der heißt FPGA zum Spaß.
Geiler Name.
Der ist guter Dinge, dass er das noch hinkriegt.
Aber das würde dann das Ende der Fahnenstange sein.
Dann ist der FPGA einfach ausgelastet.
Ein Dreamcast.
Na, Dreamcast auf gar keinen Fall.
Also mich wundert es schon,
dass PS1 und N64 überhaupt möglich ist.
Oder N64 nicht,
aber dass PS1 jetzt schon möglich ist.
Hier, da hinten haben sie
die klassische
EZ-Karre rumstehen.
Wisst ihr,
was mich bei diesen Dingern immer richtig nervt?
Dass du die nicht richtig
vorwärts steuern kannst.
Weil die haben nur
Hintenräder, die
steuerbar sind und vorne nicht.
Und manchmal musst du halt auch vorwärts fahren,
anstatt rückwärts.
Ich mochte diese Wege nie.
Ich fand die immer richtig, richtig eklig.
Zumal das auch alles runterrutscht.
Wir haben teilweise, der Felix und ich,
wir haben hier schon auf solchen Kisten,
das mag ein
Skill-Issue sein,
aber wir haben schon hier auf diesen Kisten
30.000 Euro pro
Loadbalancer, also so
Loadbalancer-Appliance drauf rumgefahren.
Vier, fünf Stück aufeinander.
Und wir sind da quasi mit
150.000 Euro über die Straße gelaufen.
Und der Gehweg
war schepp und auf der einen Seite sind die Dinger immer
fast runtergerutscht. Also ich weiß nicht,
warum die uns mit so einer Schrottkarre hier,
mit so einer Schrott,
ähm, Schrottwagen
so teure Kisten haben rumfahren lassen
in Frankfurt.
Aber gut, anscheinend nicht verkehrt.
Weil
es ist nie was kaputt gegangen.
Das einzige, was ich je mitbekommen hab,
wo Server runtergefallen sind,
war mal ein DL380
von HP.
Der ist doch HP, nicht Dell.
HP.
Und der ist nicht einfach runtergefallen.
Der ist runtergefallen und ist einem
auf den Fuß gefallen. Und der war erst mal
zwei Wochen dann
außer Gefecht. Aber wenn ihr so
ein, das Ding wiegt ja bestimmt voll
bestückt mit Festplatten, wiegt
ja bestimmt 30 Kilo oder so.
Die Dinger sind ja schwer
as fuck. Und wenn dir das so aus Tragehöhe
auf den Fuß fällt, du hast natürlich keine
Sicherheitsschuhe an und sowas,
das haut schon einiges kaputt im Fuß.
Nee, auf keinen Fall.
Also mein Traum ist ja immer noch,
was ich irgendwann mal gerne ausprobieren will,
ist, wie schnell ein Playcenter
werden kann bei vollem Lüfterbetrieb,
wenn du es auf ordentlich gelagerte Rollen stellst.
Ich geb zu,
ist schwierig nachzubauen,
aber diese Lüfter haben schon ordentlich Power.
Ja, dann schon auch die, sag ich mal,
großen 32-Bit-Konsolen, die kriegst du
in diesem FPGA nicht mehr abgebildet halt.
Kannst du mir nochmal
sagen, wie teuer ist denn das jetzt?
Also wenn du wirklich nur ein Basic-Paket von dem
Mista nimmst, da kriegst du
im Endeffekt nur das FPGA-Board.
Da hast du alle Schnittstellen dran, HDMI,
Netzwerk, MicroSD.
Ach, es gibt sogar ein HDMI-Output, okay.
Ich hätte gedacht, die haben auch eher so
ein Klassiker noch, so S-Video
oder sowas.
Und ums Upscalen musst du dich dann selbst kümmern.
Karte und ein USB-Anschluss.
Dann holst du dir noch ein USB-Hub, damit du überhaupt
Kontrolle anschließen kannst.
Und das FPGA-Board kostet
220 Euro ungefähr halt.
Du brauchst noch ein Netzteil. Also du kommst
auf jeden Fall unter 300 Euro in der Minimalausstattung
weg. Wenn du ein bisschen mehr Komfort
haben willst, sprich mehr USB-Schnittstellen,
wenn du einen optischen Tonausgang
brauchst, wenn du einen VGA,
einen analogen Bildausgang brauchst, brauchst du noch
Zusatzboards, genau, ein Gehäuse.
Vollausstattung zusammengebaut, da bist du dann schon
so 600 Euro los.
Ordentlich. Dann geh doch mal in Supernet
für 600 Euro kannst du dir einen richtig
schnellen Mini-PC kaufen schon.
Aber gut, der ist dann halt
nicht so exakt,
wenn man
alte Konsolen spielen will, wie das Ding.
Dafür hast du halt
viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Nintendo rein. Jetzt liegt da den Core,
dass er jetzt quasi dem FPGA
sagt, du bist jetzt ein Super Nintendo.
Und dann kann man die Spiele hier auswählen.
Also das Menü ist, man sieht's, schwarz-weiß.
Es ist absolut schlicht bis
hässlich, aber zum Auswählen von
Spielen reicht es aus.
Es gibt ja zum Beispiel in der Retro-Art-Community
gibt's sowas wie Retro-Achievements,
dass man so für alte Spiele Achievements
bekommt. Ist das da auch ein...
Ich hab mir ne Mini-PC was gebastelt, ja.
Ich hab auch so Dinge wie Retro-Achievements
und sowas da drinne, ja. Aber
das ist dann halt nicht so exakt
und detailgetreu
wie
der Mister, wenn's um Super Nintendo
und sowas geht. Also wenn man da Wert
drauf legt, dass es exakt so ist
wie auf der Original-Hardware alles,
so wenig
wie möglich lag,
ist es
vielleicht echt noch ne Überlegung wert.
Das kenn ich.
Ne, das gibt's da nicht.
Also was kann ich jetzt noch zusätzlich machen, was ich mit der normalen
Konsole nicht machen könnte?
Also du könntest jetzt hier quasi noch ein paar
Videofilter dazuschalten
als Beispiel. Also man kann Scanline-Filter
aktivieren, das
simuliert dann diesen zeilenartigen Bildaufbau
von diesen alten Röhrenfernseher.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel auch Cores
specific welche, die sind dann auf das
NES ausgelegt. Zum Beispiel Super Nintendo
Scanlines. Zack.
Sieht aus wie auf dem Röhrenfernseher jetzt.
Und wenn ich das jetzt anmache, dann sieht
man gleich, dass hier dieser typische
Effekt von einem Röhrenmonitor dann abgebildet
wird. Da haben die sich richtig Mühe gegeben, das sieht
super authentisch aus. Kannst auch ein
Fünffachscaling machen, nennt sich das. Also dann
skaliert er die alte Auflösung von
320x216
1080p hoch, Full HD. Dann hast du
quasi ne pixelperfekte Skalierung.
Ich würde aber jetzt aus dem Gefühl sagen,
dass das mehr aussieht wie ein Röhrenfernseher.
Weil da, also da baut er jetzt hier
noch Scanlines ein. Da ist halt noch so ne
Ein bisschen mehr, ne. Sieht noch ein bisschen echter
aus sozusagen. Du kannst auch nen WLAN
Dongle an den Nista hängen. Dann bist du im Internet
und dann kannst du dir über... Ach ich dachte
es hat nen RJ45 Stecker hinten gehabt.
...Date-Skripte. Ganz simpel dann
die neuen Cores holen oder neue
Videofilter oder so. Das ist alles mehr oder weniger
automatisiert. Ich benutze ehrlich gesagt
auf dem Raspi benutze ich halt
wirklich auch so Funktionen wie Save Games. Also
dass ich abspeichere, obwohl ich die Funktionen
im Spiel eigentlich nicht gibt und zurückspulen.
Das hat ja sogar... Die haben doch auf dem
Nista sicherlich noch ne normale CPU
drauf, wo irgendein Mini-Linux oder so läuft.
Allein schon für das On-Screen-Menü
und
für Update-Funktionalität und sowas.
Das hat der Nista wahrscheinlich
auch nicht, ne? Also der Nista ist, sagen wir mal so
auf Authentizität... Ja, so Sachen
wie Save Games sind schon enorm praktisch.
Wenn man alte Games spielt.
Wenn ich mir überlege,
damals musstest du noch zu irgendeinem Speicherpunkt
rennen, sowas weiß ich. Die Mutter kommt rein
und sagt hier, oh, wir müssen jetzt unbedingt los.
Dann musst du erstmal zurück ins nächste Dorf speichern
und sowas. Ja.
Das war damals
halt doof.
Und das ist heute im Prinzip immer noch doof.
So Sachen wie Save Games sind einfach praktisch.
Das ist das Erlebnis genauso
wie früher ist und das ist in dem Bereich natürlich
ein riesen Nachteil, ne? Weil klar, wenn du jetzt
immer mal wieder Super Nintendo spielst,
genau an der Stelle, wo früher das Super Nintendo
speichern konnte, auf der Batterie
im Spielmodul, kannst du auch speichern,
aber es gibt nur eine Handvoll
Cores, die diese Save States
bieten, also dass du zu jedem Zeitpunkt speichern kannst.
Der NES Core kann das,
der Playstation 1 Core kann das.
Die Cores, die das nicht können, die werden es wahrscheinlich
auch niemals können, weil das extrem
aufwendig ist. Also im Grunde muss der Core
von Grund auf mit Save State im Hinterkopf
entwickelt werden, weil sonst ist es so komplex,
dass du es nicht hinkriegst. Und Rückspulfunktionen
gab es früher im Kinderzimmer nicht
und gibt es bei Nista dann auch nicht, ne?
Kleiner Nachteil, aber du kannst zum Beispiel Cheats aktivieren,
die fast für jedes Spiel, findest du Cheats halt,
aber dann kannst du dich unbesiegbar machen oder
machst dir 99 Leben bei Mario oder
was weiß ich noch, ja. Und hier habe ich halt,
ich meine, das ist halt schon ein großer
Unterschied, ne? Also wenn ich jetzt in
das Menü reingehe, dann
habe ich einen Packshot zu jedem Spiel, ich habe
ein Video zu jedem Spiel.
Punkto Optik schlägt der Raspi das natürlich
um Welten, ne? Ja.
Mein Fazit. Der große Vorteil
ist einfach nahezu verzögerungsfrei.
Und den Unterschied merke sogar ich,
der absolut kein Pro Gamer ist.
Aber wenn man natürlich so Spiele spielt wie Pokémon,
dann muss man sich so ein Ding nicht anschaffen,
dann bringt das nichts. Ansonsten hat der
Nista gegenüber so einem Raspi halt
viele Nachteile. Deutlich teurer,
ab 300 Euro bis 600 Euro. Na gut,
Raspberry Pis sind halt auch leider
unsinnig teuer.
Wobei ich habe gehört, Chatge,
dass es mittlerweile angeblich
mit dem Lieferengpass nicht mehr ganz so schlimm
ist. Wir müssen gleich mal gucken. Viele Cores haben
keine Safe Games, er hat keine
Retro Achievements, das Menü
deutlich hässlicher und deutlich
schwieriger als beim Raspi.
Der Raspi 4 zum Vergleich hat Vorteile.
Günstig, super flexibel,
kann zum Beispiel auch Dreamcast emulieren,
das kann das FPGA-System nicht.
Man kann zurückspulen, man hat Safe Games,
super. Der Nachteil ist
allerdings, man hat einen leichten Lag, vielleicht
5 Frames oder so, den hat man bei dem
FPGA-System nicht. Also, wenn man
jetzt mal so eine Empfehlung aussprechen soll, geht nicht,
ist eine total individuelle Sache. Das heißt,
wenn es euch darum geht, absolut das
Original-System nachzubilden und euch wirklich
2 Frames latent...
Hat jemand eine Idee, woher der Lag
kommt beim Emulieren?
Ich persönlich vermute ja
über den USB-Input, oder?
Nicht von der Emulation
selbst. Also,
ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, dass
eine alte Konsole direkt den Input
poilen konnte, jeden Frame,
was ein
Emulator,
was auf einem aktuellen Betriebssystem
läuft, halt nicht machen kann.
Also, daher vermute ich
mal, dass es daher
kommt. Warum?
Wissen tue ich es nicht, ehrlich
gesagt. Aber du hast halt keinen
direkten Zugriff auf
irgendwelche Controller-States
und sowas von
einem Emulator.
Weil das aktuelle
Betriebssysteme halt einfach nicht erlauben.
Also, ich denke mal, da kommt das
her. Das liegt nicht am Emulator
selbst. Der Emulator kann
schlicht und ergreifend halt einfach nicht
jeden Frame den Input abfragen.
Und dann
muss,
sobald der Input da ist,
kann er da auch gesagt werden, okay,
wie muss sich das Game jetzt verhalten?
Und dementsprechend
dann ergibt das auch Sinn
mit diesem
Ahead of Time, was die eben
erzählt haben. Die rechnen
einfach Frames im Voraus
für, wenn der Spieler
jetzt gedrückt hätte. Und dann
können sie quasi direkt da drauf springen,
sobald der Input vorliegt.
Also, ich gehe davon aus, dass es eben an
modernen Betriebssystemen und
den
nicht möglichen direkten
Zugriff auf Controller-Inputs
zusammenhängt.
Es liegt nicht direkt am
Emulator selbst, weil es emulieren würde.
Rate ich jetzt mal. Hab mich damit nicht
weiter beschäftigt.
Also, wenn man jetzt mal so eine Empfehlung aussprechen
soll, geht nicht. Ist eine total individuelle
Sache. Das heißt, wenn es euch darum geht,
absolut das Original-System nachzubilden,
und euch wirklich zwei Frames
Latenz auffallen, und ihr solche Spiele
spielt, bei denen das auch eine Rolle spielt,
dann solltet ihr euch den Mistler etwas genauer
angucken, bei allen anderen, denen es um
Komfort geht und solche Geschichten.
Dann nehmt kein Raspberry Pi, sondern nehmt
nen Mini-PC, wenn ihr ein bisschen mehr Kohle
ausgeben wollt. Vielleicht mit diesen zwei Frames
leben könnt, dann seid ihr mit nem
Raspi 4 oder nem alten gebrauchten
Thin Client seid ihr besser betrieben. Oder
nem ordentlich modernen Mini-PC,
weil da kannst du auch so Sachen wie Wii
Scaled spielen.
Ja, wie seht ihr das? Seid ihr da empfindlich, was
Latenz angeht? Merkt ihr das? Dann schreibt's gerne in die Kommentare.
Und natürlich abonnieren. Tschüss.
See you.
Ja, so sieht's aus. Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Und jetzt, komm, jetzt gucken wir uns das Video von
Fireship an.
Weil irgendjemand vorhin gemeint hat, hier, guck mal,
HTMX.
Da gibt's auch ein Video von Fireship. Lass uns das mal
schnell zu Gemüte führen. Geht auch nur
2 Minuten 26.
Okay, ein neues
JavaScript-Framework, das hat die Welt
gebraucht. Yeah!
...
Was?
Alles klar.
...
Moment, das ist quasi
Server-Side-Rendering
in Kombination mit
Client-Dings. Was bin
ich da sehend überhaupt?
Der Render das dann auf dem Server schickt zurück
und dann wird's replaced.
Aber warum sollte ich das nicht mit
Client-Side-JavaScript machen?
Ist das nicht sinniger? Vor allem, wie müsste
ich die Server-Seite aufbauen, dass das funktioniert?
Man weiß es nicht.
Wir werden's gleich sehen.
...
Das ist Fireship, ja.
Ach so, jetzt habe ich das kapiert.
Der ruft einfach die gleiche Seite nochmal ab
und tauscht dann nur das aus,
was sich geändert hat auf dem Element, oder wie.
Und das ist schneller?
Ja gut, du musst die Seite nicht reloaden.
Ja, okay, verstehe ich.
Okay, ja, leuchtet ein.
Wirkt zwar ein bisschen oldschool in Zeiten von Kleinzeit-JavaScript,
das umfangreicher ist als die Server-Seite,
aber wenn du noch ein bisschen was Älteres hast,
was du fit machen willst,
vielleicht was sich ein bisschen schneller anfühlt,
ist das doch gut.
Wobei, was ich halt nicht verstehe, ist,
warum man komplett, wenn man eine neue Anwendung baut,
es damit machen sollte.
... allows us to move the UI to a completely different element.
It finds that element with a CSS selector,
but has additional syntax like next and closest,
allowing you to easily...
find the proper element without a bunch of custom IDs.
We might also use HTMX Indicator to show a loading spinner
and write a CSS transition animation for the incoming element.
Behind the scenes, HTMX has an extensive event system
that you can tap into by listening to custom events with JavaScript.
And if you want...
What?
Ja, dann kann ich doch einfach Kleinzeit-JavaScript verwenden, oder?
Dann brauche ich doch HTMX nicht.
... want to run your own client-side JavaScript,
the HX-on-Attribute allows you to bind a JavaScript...
... JavaScript function...
Den Sinn habe ich noch nicht, die Sinnhaftigkeit habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden.
... to any element.
And that's all it takes to build a highly polished full-stack HTML application
on the information superhighway.
This has been HTMX in 100 seconds.
Alles klar. Mach ich das Ding erinnern, sehr gute Idee.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Okay, warum ich das jetzt verwenden sollte, habe ich trotzdem noch nicht kapiert.
Habt ihr das gecheckt, Chat?
Ach so, wenn JavaScript kacke ist,
ich kann kein Deutsch, ich bin Englisch.
No worries, I'm English expert.
And yes, this was a Fireship-Video.
JavaScript nutzen ohne JavaScript nutzen müssen.
Ja, anscheinend, anscheinend, ja.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht genau, was man damit machen soll.
Was auch immer.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, was HTMX ist.
Eine Sache, wo ich jetzt aktuell nicht wüsste, wozu ich sie brauche und auch nicht ganz sicher bin,
welche Probleme sie löst.
Aber wenn man sie mal braucht, dann ist sie da.
Okay?
Ja, nee, so genau habe ich es jetzt auch nicht gecheckt, warum man das braucht.
Man weiß es nicht.
Alter, ich will kein Chat-GPT-Video gucken.
YouTube, please.
Beschleunigte Entwicklung.
Ja, aber, ja, eigentlich nicht, oder?
Wenn du was Neues anfängst, dann kannst du auch einfach Svelte, React, Vue oder sonst was benutzen.
Und dann hast du noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Und dann kannst du es wirklich auch kleinzeitig machen, ohne jedes Mal die neue Seite zu pollen.
Also, ich hätte jetzt gesagt, das ist eher was, um etwas ältere Anwendungen zu beschleunigen.
Genau, also, richtig gecheckt habe ich es nicht.
Welchen Bluetooth-Adapter könnt ihr empfehlen, wenn ich einen Xiaomi Blinks-Thermometer mit dem...
Moment.
Welche, welche ist denn das?
Das da!
Tja, exzellent.
Also, das erste, was du mit dem Ding machen solltest, ist Custom-Firmware drauf flashen.
Hast du das Teil hier?
Genau das? Das habe ich nämlich auch ein paar von.
Die will ich erst kaufen.
Also, es reicht jeder x-beliebige Bluetooth-Adapter.
Ich glaube...
Ich überlege gerade, wie ich den Empfang mache.
Ah, ich mache den Empfang mit einem ESP32, der bei mir im Bad hängt.
Aber das ist nicht schlimm, weil...
Es gibt ja mittlerweile Bluetooth-Proxys für Home Assistant.
Du kannst...
Also, entweder machst du einen Bluetooth-Adapter...
Also, einen Bluetooth-Adapter brauchst du auf jeden Fall an deinem Home Assistant dran.
Aber wenn die Reichweite nicht reicht, kannst du ESP32...
Kannst du Bluetooth-Proxys benutzen.
Warning.
Also, da kannst du ESP32 zum Verlängern von Bluetooth-Verbindungen benutzen, wenn es nicht reicht.
Es ist egal.
Du kannst dir irgendeinen Bluetooth-Adapter kaufen.
Du solltest aber unbedingt...
Du solltest aber unbedingt Custom-Firmware installieren auf den Dingern.
Es gibt ein paar Forks hiervon.
Ihm hatte ich mal ein paar Thermometer geschickt zum Basteln und Ausprobieren.
Aber es gibt noch ein paar Forks davon.
Ja.
Musst du dir mal angucken.
Es ist sehr sinnvoll, Custom-Firmware drauf zu installieren in dem Fall.
Und es ist auch sehr einfach.
Du kannst es direkt über einen Browser machen von einem Rechner, der Bluetooth hat.
Also, am besten von deiner Windows-Kiste aus.
Unter Linux und Raspberry Pi gibt es Probleme mit dem Bluetooth-Stack im Browser.
Es gibt so eine Flash-Seite.
Hier, da gehst du hin.
So.
Und dann kannst du hier Bluetooth scannen über den Browser und flashen.
Der Vorteil ist, du kannst dann jede Menge Sachen einstellen an diesen Thermometern.
Zum Beispiel, in welchem Intervall die Sensoren abfragen.
Und in welchem Intervall die Daten raussteigen.
Weil das normale Thermometer fragt alle paar Sekunden ab.
Und verschickt, glaube ich, sogar auch alle zwei Sekunden den neuen Stand.
Alle zwei Sekunden verbraucht halt extrem viel Batterie.
Ich habe es hochgestellt, dass er nur alle 15 Minuten verschickt.
Und ich habe das erste Moment.
Ich gucke mal nach, Leute.
Ich sage euch, wann ich das erste gekauft habe.
Und das ist jetzt fast leer.
Das ist jetzt bei 4 Prozent.
Äh.
Hier, 5. April 2021 habe ich das erste gekauft.
Das hält noch ein bisschen.
Sagen wir mal, das hält über, weit über zwei Jahre, so eine kleine Batterie da drinnen.
Und die hält aber auch nur so lang, weil ich es eben hochgedreht habe auf 15 Minuten.
Also alle 15 Minuten.
Ich warte jetzt mal, bis die wirklich leer geht.
Ja.
Also ich denke mal, dass es durchaus, oder je nachdem, wenn du es noch ein bisschen besser tunest.
Meine Firmware, die ich drauf geflasht habe, war auch nicht die allerneuste im Vergleich zu dem, was es heute gibt.
Vielleicht gibt es ja noch ein paar Optimierungen.
Also zwei bis zweieinhalb Jahre.
Eher zweieinhalb Jahre hält die Batterie, wenn du das angepasst hast.
Und dann lohnt sich das.
Ich finde, in Originalausführungen lohnt es sich gar nicht so sehr.
Dann brauchst du alle dreiviertel Jahr eine neue Batterie.
Das ist kacke.
Da musst du dann fast zweimal im Jahr durchs Haus rennen.
Aber zweieinhalb Jahre, sagen wir mal, knapp zweieinhalb Jahre, ist schon nice.
Ja.
Ich muss mal gucken, Leute, ob wir es schaffen.
Ob wir heute Abend noch ein bisschen flashen im Stream.
Weil ich muss heute eigentlich noch ein paar Sachen machen.
Und theoretisch sogar noch ein Video aufnehmen, falls wir das heute hinbekommen.
Ihr erinnert euch noch daran, dass ich letztens ein bisschen was erzählt habe.
So was ich hier an komischen Aktionen von europäischen E-Sport Organisationen die letzten Jahre über immer mitbekommen habe.
Wir haben uns jetzt dazu entschieden, da doch mal öffentlich ein Video zuzumachen.
Also mit einem, der es aus erster Hand berichten kann.
Aber wahrscheinlich werden wir keine Namen sagen.
Aber bloß, was da für eine Scheiße abläuft.
Ich meine, ich mache zwar jetzt relativ wenig noch E-Sport Gaming bezogenen Content, aber ich gucke halt selbst schon lange.
Und es gibt ein paar Sachen, da muss man einfach öffentlich mal was zu sagen.
Dass gerade auch neue Spieler wissen, auf was sie sich da für einen Shit einlassen.
AliExpress liefert nicht nach Österreich.
Du musst mal gucken, AliExpress hat ja tausend verschiedene Shops.
Es gibt ja nicht AliExpress als Shop.
AliExpress ist ja eher ein Marketplace.
Pato, herrli, dankeschön für den Sub.
Du musst einfach mal gucken, ob es andere Anbieter gibt, die nach Österreich liefern.
Ja, das lohnt sich übrigens auch tatsächlich nur, wenn man die besonders günstig bei AliExpress kaufen kann.
Ich hatte ja auch mal so ein Zehnerpack bestellt bei AliExpress für ein abgelohntes Ei pro Thermostat.
Dann lohnt sich das.
Leute, heute gibt es, ratet mal, was es zu essen gibt heute.
Reis? Nein.
Kein Reis.
Auch nicht.
Suppe.
Leute, entweder gebatet ihr mich jetzt, oder ihr wisst es wirklich nicht.
Nudeln mit Lachs?
Nein, auch nicht.
Es gibt Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce.
Weil die von gestern noch übrig ist.
Aber ich habe gedacht, ich gebatet euch mal, weil die meisten ja immer der Meinung sind, ich futter nur noch Nudeln und Lachs.
Teedili, dankeschön für den Sub.
Schnitzel.
Oh, Schnitzel.
Ich habe letztens mega nice was gefuttert.
Und zwar, passt mal auf.
Mal schauen.
Leute, wir tricksen Twitter jetzt aus.
Wir machen jetzt Twitter Gebatet.
Kann man Twitter Image Links aufmachen?
Ha, das funktioniert.
Gebatet Twitter.
Gebatet.
You got gebatet.
You got, you got gebatet.
Genau.
Also, letztens mega nice gefuttert.
Ab und zu, paar mal im Jahr, kann man sich sowas gönnen.
Auch wenn Essen gehen extrem teuer geworden ist.
Ja, Lamm, Rind und Schwein.
Glaube ich, wenn ich das jetzt richtig aus dem Links sehe.
Und Porras Bratkartoffeln.
Hat mega geschmeckt.
Aber ist teuer geworden.
Richtig teuer.
Ich würde gerne Temperaturen auf meinem Balkon messen.
Batterie und Plutus.
Könnt ihr mir da was empfehlen?
Ja.
Nämlich genau das, was Teddy Leaf vor 5 Minuten im Stream gepostet hat.
Das Ding.
Aber nur, wenn du ein bisschen basteln möchtest.
Wenn du nicht basteln möchtest, gibt es andere Varianten.
Wenn du basteln möchtest, finde ich das preis-leistungsmäßig mit Abstand das Beste.
Basteln heißt, du kaufst dir die Dinge am besten bei AliExpress.
Weil bei AliExpress kriegst du die für unter 9 Euro das Stück, zumindest.
Gab es das mal?
Gucken wir mal kurz.
AliExpress.
Wie nennen das die Amis eigentlich?
AliExpress?
Oder Thermometer?
Ja, die Dinger.
Okay, es ist ein bisschen teurer geworden.
Hier gibt es auch eines für 1,28 Euro.
Aber das ist AliExpress G-Bait.
Das willst du haben.
7,68 Euro.
Sehr schön.
Ja, da kaufst du dir gleich einen 10er-Pack.
10er-Pack.
Hier.
39 Euro.
Durch...
Alter, durch 10.
Das muss man...
3-Head, Alter.
39 durch 10.
Was könnte das wohl sein?
So.
Aber das ist halt enorm billig dann.
Guck mal, kannst du das Komma hier einfach verschieben.
Das ist enorm billig, das Stück.
Für den Außenbereich.
Nee, für den Außenbereich ist es nicht gut.
Aber willst du den Außenbereich wirklich zahlen?
Ist das wirklich im Regen oder ist es unter einem Dach?
Solange es unter einem Dach hängt, ist es vollkommen in Ordnung.
Nee, war ich nicht.
Auf dem Balkon, da ist doch ein Dach drüber.
Das ist gar kein Ding.
Das hängst du einfach an die Wand über.
Wenn du es natürlich ins Freie hängen willst, wo wirklich direkt der Wasser,
Wassereinstrahlung, Regeneinstrahlung, Sonneneinstrahlung und alles Hagel und so drauf,
dann ist das nichts.
Aber wenn du es auf dem Balkon hängst,
da ist es ja meistens unterm Dach,
dann ist es vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ja, du musst es aber flashen mit Custom Firmware
und das Intervall, wie das die Daten sendet, etwas runterstellen.
Dann kommst du auf knapp zweieinhalb Jahre mit so einer Mini-Batterie.
Das ist das günstigste und beste Thermometer, also Luftfeuchtigkeit-Thermometer,
in der Kombination, was ich mir denken kann.
Es hält ewig mit einer Knopfzellenbatterie
und es ist billig as fuck.
Und du brauchst halt irgendeinen Stick, irgendeinen Bluetooth-Stick zum Empfangen.
Name kurz hier, da kannst du AliExpress, da.
Diese Dinger.
Musst halt gucken, dass du irgendwie eins da findest, wo es billiger ist.
Und das ist das, was ich meinte mit AliExpress.
Das gibt es halt verschiedenste.
Gucken wir mal. Österreich.
Austria.
Sprache österreichisch.
Gibt es nicht.
Wie, Deutsch? Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Das ist doch kein Deutsch.
Ja.
Die liefern, die liefern hier, die liefern nicht nach Österreich.
Gucken wir mal die an.
Die liefern auch nicht nach Österreich.
Warum liefern die alle nicht nach Österreich?
Was ist das?
Was ist da los? Warum liefern die nicht nach Österreich?
Chrome noch schneller machen.
Quatsch, ich habe genug RAM, wir müssen nichts noch schneller machen.
So.
Kein Versand nach Österreich, kein Versand nach Österreich, kein Versand.
Was ist denn da los?
Warum schicken die alle nicht nach Österreich?
Was haben die da wieder, was machen die Österreicher dann wieder für komische Dinger?
Warum verschickt AliExpress nicht nach Österreich?
Hä?
Okay.
Alles klar.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Hängt alles beim Zoll.
Ja, aber das ist doch, innerhalb der EU wird das doch verschickt.
AliExpress schickt doch erst nach Österreich.
Oder nach Spanien oder Niederlande oder Frankreich oder so.
Und von dort dann weiter.
Also es hängt auch nicht im Zoll.
Ich habe noch nicht einmal was im Zoll hängen gehabt von AliExpress.
Weil das alles innerhalb der EU ist.
Aber gut, vielleicht machen die Ösis da irgendwelche komischen Dinger.
Weiß ich nicht.
Wenn was nicht ankommt bei AliExpress, machst du bei AliExpress direkt einen Problemlösungsfall auf.
Und du hast Instant, also Instant ist übertrieben, du hast ratzfatz dein Geld wieder.
Also ich muss sagen.
Ich habe mit AliExpress echt nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Die haben noch nicht einmal darauf gewartet, bis der Hersteller das überhaupt,
also die haben den Hersteller sich nicht einmal rausreden lassen.
Ich habe zwei Tage nicht geantwortet.
Also gingen sie davon aus, ich war nicht zufrieden und habe das Geld zurückbekommen.
Da war vor ein paar Monaten mal was.
Okay.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Flashen und Installieren?
Ah, das ist jetzt ein bisschen so eine esoterische Frage.
Aber ich würde sagen, Flashen heißt halt, du tauschst die Firmware auf einem, auf einem...
Speicher, Flash-Speicher-Chip aus, von der das Gerät bootet.
Und installieren ist, du hast ein Betriebssystem, was läuft und installierst halt quasi,
du tauschst nicht das Betriebssystem und alles komplett aus, sondern du installierst halt was zusätzlich,
was du dann ausführen kannst.
Ja, ist ein bisschen, bisschen, tja, bisschen so, was soll ich sagen, philosophische Frage,
wie man, an welch, wie man das untereinander abgrenzt.
Aber mit Flashen ist eigentlich immer gemeint,
man tauscht eben die Software, die auf einem Flash-Speicher von irgendeinem Controller ist, aus, gegen was Eigenes.
Man könnte auch sagen, ich installiere das da drauf.
Aber mit Flashen weiß jeder, was gemeint ist.
Das Milfra-Zeug getestet?
Nee, das ist aber angekommen.
Ich habe es schon auseinandergebaut und festgestellt, da ist ein ESP-2866 noch drin.
OTA-Flashen scheinen nicht richtig zu funktionieren.
Vielleicht habe ich es auch einfach nicht oft genug ausprobiert.
Aber ich habe Debug-Pins.
Das heißt, wir sollten es von Hand flashen können.
Solange ich, solange ich nicht GPIO 0 auf Ground, äh, legen muss,
dass es flashbar wird, weil das ist sehr, sehr klein alles.
Also, wenn ich Zeit habe, probiere ich es heute aus.
Heute Abend können wir es zusammen ausprobieren.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das, ob das hinhaut.
Wie sieht es aus?
Hogu!
Ja, ist es auch.
Ich mag MongoDB überhaupt nicht.
Haben wir, haben wir MongoDB-Fans hier, Leute?
MongoDB war ultra-gehypt, aber es ist die letzten Jahre, oder schon einige Jahre jetzt,
nicht, nicht einfach nur die letzten Jahre, bestimmt die letzten fünf Jahre über schon,
recht still um MongoDB geworden.
Ich glaube, das wird benutzt, immer noch, und es ist halt immer, es ist halt angekommen mittlerweile.
Aber so diesen Hauch des, das beste ever, hat es nicht mehr.
Also, wenn du mich fragst, wenn ich, welche Datenbank ich verwenden würde, standardmäßig,
dann ist es nicht MongoDB.
Wenn, wenn ich, wenn mich jemand fragen würde,
Max, wir wissen noch nicht so genau, was wir machen wollen, hundertprozentig, und wie wir das aufbauen,
welche Datenbank würdest du empfehlen?
Dann würde ich sagen, immer Postgres.
Ja.
Weil mit Postgres kannst du nahezu alles machen, was du machen willst, auch Time-Series-Datenbanken,
auch Key-Value-Stores, aber halt in manchen Spezialfällen nicht so performant, wie das jetzt in einer speziellen,
optimierten Datenbank dafür wäre, ja.
Also mal angenommen, du willst wirklich alles schemalos, reine String-Key-Value-Geschichte oder so speichern,
kannst du das in Postgres machen, auch relativ gut.
Gibt es ja mittlerweile Extensions für, dass das richtig gut funktioniert.
Aber einen Ticken besser dürftest du performancetechnisch wahrscheinlich dann immer noch mit MongoDB
oder, ja, den tausend anderen NoSQL-Dingern sein.
Aber wenn du flexibel sein willst, würde ich einfach immer Postgres verwenden.
Postgres ist einfach mega pock.
Du kannst in Postgres, zum Beispiel, nur mal so zum Vergleich, ja.
Du kannst in Postgres ganz klassische, relationales Datenbankgedöns machen.
Ganz normales SQL oder Sequel, wie es manche Leute nennen, die ich jetzt einmal weirdchampen muss.
Also kannst du in Postgres ganz normale SQL-Abfragen machen, so wie man das kann,
so wie man das kennt und so wie man das vielleicht auch kann.
Und ganz alles klassisch in Postgres.
Dann kannst du in Postgres Fulltext-Search machen,
ohne dass du zusätzliche Sachen wie Elasticsearch oder so gedönst machen musst, ja.
Direkt eingebaut.
Was übrigens SQLite sogar auch kann.
Wenn auch nicht so gut.
Du kannst Fulltext-Search machen.
Du kannst einen Fulltext-Search-Index aufbauen in Postgres.
Du kannst zusätzlich zu diesem Fulltext-Search in Postgres auch noch, das nennt sich, Trigram-Search machen.
Da muss man jetzt nicht wissen, was das ist.
Aber man kann mit Trigram-Search Sub-Strings suchen.
Das geht ja mit reiner Fulltext-Search nicht.
Reine Fulltext-Search geht auf komplette Wörter, die durch bestimmte Trennzeichen, meistens Leerzeichen, Kommas und so getrennt sind.
Trigram-Search indiziert das Ganze quasi immer in Dreierbuchstabenblöcken.
Das heißt, du kannst Sub-String-Search machen, was extrem pock ist, wenn du so Autocomplete-Felder machen willst.
Ja, also wenn du sowas hier bauen willst.
Hier, so Autocomplete-Felder.
Dann ist das einfach mega nice und super schnell.
Da kommst du mit Fulltext-Search nicht sonderlich weit.
Das kannst du in Postgres machen.
Du kannst in Postgres Timeseries-Datenbank hier, Postgres Timescale-Extension, kannst du in Postgres machen.
Und du kannst auch noch so Sachen machen wie, ah ne, das ist jetzt nur für .NET.
Transactional Event-Store.
Und du kannst dann auch in Postgres auch noch relativ gut Postgres Key-Value-Store machen.
Gibt's extra Sachen für...
Und Postgres hat sogar eingebauten JSON-Support.
Da kannst du sogar JSON-Objekte querien in Postgres.
Guck, kannst du solche Abfragen machen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das nicht auch andere Datenbanken können, aber ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass die Kombination aus diesen ganzen Sachen relativ einzigartig für Postgres ist.
Beziehungsweise auch in der Verbreitung dem...
Ja, Support will ich's jetzt nicht nennen, aber durch die Verbreitung halt auch dem Know-How.
Ja, also das ist schon ziemlich einzigartig.
Igitt.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von SQL.
Ich hab das jetzt so erzählt, als bin ich der Wahnsinns-Datenbank-Checker oder so, aber das stimmt nicht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung von Datenbank und SQL.
Das ist tatsächlich einer der Punkte in der IT, wo ich sagen muss...
Wo ich von Anfang an immer sagen muss, wenn's da drum geht, hab ich keinen Plan.
Ich kenn mich recht breit in vielen Gebieten aus und ich hab natürlich auch so meine Spezial-Geschichten, aber...
Datenbanken ist echt nix davon.
Datenbanken hab ich keine Ahnung.
Hab ich bis jetzt immer einen großen Bogen drum gemacht und hab ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht vor mich da...
Ich mein, ich kann mich mit einer Postgres-Datenbank verbinden und da irgendwie...
Drop-Database machen.
Ja, das krieg ich hin.
Aber SQL-Abfragen schreiben von Hand krieg ich nicht gescheit gebacken.
Und sonstige Datenbank-Sachen krieg ich auch nicht gebacken.
Also, das ist wirklich nicht mein Fachgebiet.
Aber wie gesagt, man muss ja auch nicht alles können.
So.
Was können wir uns denn noch so angucken?
I made a 32-Bit-Computer inside Terraria.
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt wird's High-IQ, Leute.
Hat der WubLawz schon die InfluxDB-Cloud-Geschichte?
Nee, was ist damit?
News checken.
InfluxDB-Cloud... äh, konnte man hier nicht mal auf News klicken?
Bin ich jetzt verwirrt?
Hä?
Leute, gab's da nicht immer einen News-Button normalerweise bei Google?
Was ist denn das hier jetzt? Das ist neu.
So ein Shit, Alter. Was ist das hier?
Was haben sie sich da wieder ausgedacht, äh?
Was? Influx...
Data... äh, was meinst du? Ich... äh...
Die sind nicht einfach zu debuggen.
Ja, da hab ich auch keinen Plan. Ich weiß, was es ist, aber ich hab keine Ahnung davon.
Äh, was meinst du? Mit der InfluxDB-Cloud-Geschichte?
Was da... was da gewesen ist?
Ah, mich juckt's am Bein, Alter. Da hat mich irgendeine Mücke gestochen.
Die haben ein paar Regionen gelöscht. Anscheinend waren da nicht alle informiert und dann waren die Daten weg.
Ja, ich denke, man geht gerade in die Cloud, weil die Cloud-Anbieter das doch alles immer besser wissen und besser können, als man das selbst hier könnte.
Das ist eines der Argumente, die ich für Cloud immer höre.
Aber im Prinzip stimmt das natürlich schon, ja.
Also, was Microsoft, Google und, ähm, Amazon da an Ressourcen und Know-How in ihre Cloud-Plattform stecken, das kannst du nicht einfach mal so, ähm, replizieren.
Alleine mit 4-5-Mann-Team und so.
Das ist schon was dran, dass die das in der Regel doch besser wissen, wie man das betreibt.
Was aber nicht automatisch heißt, dass es für alles die beste Idee ist, das da hinzupacken.
All data deleted. A warning for those using InfluxCloudDB.
Wo läuft denn Influx? AWS oder... oder... ah, hier geht's... nee.
Oder haben die selbst irgendwelche Rechenzentren?
Europe West 1 klingt irgendwie sehr nach Google?
Warum löschen die einfach random Regionen?
Das ist... das ist ja Fail, Alter.
Okay, die haben Regionen gelöscht, weil sie wahrscheinlich sich nicht mehr rentiert haben oder was auch immer.
Und die haben den Leuten einfach nicht Bescheid gesagt, dass sie das jetzt löschen.
Die haben die Nutzer benachrichtigt, aber sind manchmal nicht angekommen.
Okay, vielleicht reden sie sich auch raus und haben nie welche verschickt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, wenn ich Regionen lösche, sodass danach nicht irgendwie gesagt wird, okay,
ihr müsst jetzt die Region ändern, vielleicht ist es latency-mäßig nicht okay, aber dann müsst ihr halt woanders migrieren.
Einfach löschen, das ist halt... das ist halt echt Fail, ja.
Also das ist halt wirklich Fail.
Und ein weiterer Grund für, warum man nicht immer blind Sachen in die Cloud migrieren sollte.
Habe BWL studiert und arbeite seit zwei Jahren im IT-Controlling.
Oje, MonkaS, Alter. Oder um nicht zu sagen...
Aber gut, jeder, worauf er Bock hat.
Deshalb etwas IT-Luft geschnuppert und seit dem Anfang des Jahres versuche ich, mich etwas mit dem Programmieren zu beschäftigen.
Free Bootcamp, die Basics von...
Die sind, glaube ich, ganz okay. Die haben doch auch einen YouTube-Channel, gell?
Ne, bring ich das durcheinander?
Ne, doch, genau. Ja, ja.
Da sind manchmal ganz brauchbare Sachen dabei.
Jetzt mache ich gerade CS50.
Was ist denn CS50?
Ist das dieses... Ja, ist es. Ich habe gerade nachgeguckt.
Ob man das braucht? Keine Ahnung.
Wenn ich das durchziehe und abschließe, würde ich meine Situation dann evaluieren.
Ah, man sieht, dass du BWL-Zeug gemacht hast im Vorfeld.
Niemand anderes würde schreiben, ich würde meine Situation dann evaluieren.
Und dann überlegen, eventuell danach in Teilzeit ein Bootcamp zu machen.
Was hältst du davon, beziehungsweise kannst du ein Bootcamp...
Ne, kann ich nicht. Weder pro noch contra.
Weil ich nie einen Bootcamp gemacht habe.
Also, keine Ahnung. Chat-Gill, was sagt ihr dazu?
Also, ich bin der Meinung, man kann das auch alles daheim selbst lernen.
Ohne Bootcamp. Vielleicht geht es mit einem Bootcamp schneller. Keine Ahnung.
Mir persönlich würden andere Menschen im Bootcamp auf den Sack gehen.
Das Beste, was ich mir immer vorstellen kann zum Programmieren lernen, ist,
man hat vielleicht das ein oder andere Projekt, was man persönlich interessant findet,
sucht sich die Programmiersprache und Technologie dazu aus und fängt an.
Ja, im Prinzip sagt der Chat das, was ich auch gerade gesagt habe.
Was für Bereiche interessieren dich denn? Sind es eher Frontend-Web-Interface-Sachen?
Sind das eher Server-seitige Backend-Geschichten?
Ist es irgendwie Machine Learning? Ist es Microcontroller-Programmieren?
Was sind denn so die Bereiche, die dir gefallen?
Vielleicht sind es auch Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen.
Was sind die Bereiche, die dir gefallen?
Und in dem Bereich würde ich mir tatsächlich die beste Technologie raussuchen und einfach anfangen.
Und mach dir einen GitHub-Account.
Mach dir einen GitHub-Account.
Wenn du ein bisschen was auf die Reihe bekommst und wenn du dich bewirbst, kannst du den mit verlinken.
Das kommt immer gut an.
Sogar bei mir, und ich bin nicht hauptberuflicher Softwareentwickler, kam das gut an, dass ich einen GitHub-Account habe.
Wir haben sogar über manche Projekte gesprochen auf meinem GitHub-Account im Vorstellungsgespräch.
Das ist übrigens auch der einzige Grund, warum ich meine Projekte ordentlich sortiert habe auf GitHub.
Das wird nie wieder vorkommen, außer ich bewerbe mich mal wieder neu.
Damals war White Paper Happy Background noch nicht drinne.
Wir haben uns sogar hier drüber unterhalten, über Elektroauto-Kram.
Also das kann ich nur empfehlen.
Ja, also erzähl mal, was die Bereiche sind, die dir gefallen.
Da kann man vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zu sagen.
Umfrage für was?
An das Trinken erinnern.
Ob Bootcamps sich lohnen?
Achso, ja. Okay, das ist eine gute Idee, das können wir tatsächlich machen.
Wie heißt denn das richtig?
Lohnen sich...
Wie nennt man sowas?
Programmier-Bootcamps?
Wie heißt denn sowas?
Ich hab halt keine Ahnung, wie sich sowas nennt.
Coding-Bootcamps.
Schreibt man Bootcamps zusammen oder auseinander?
Zusammen.
Ja.
Was machen wir da für Anfragen?
Ja, nein, vielleicht.
Kommt drauf an.
Okay.
Start.
Chat gehen.
Bist du überhaupt noch da?
Wir hatten das gefragt.
Demodimi?
Achso.
Ich habe natürlich zu Beginn etwas mit Python und JavaScript.
Das ist eine gute Sache zum Anfang.
Aber finde ich grundsätzlich auch interessant.
Im FE sehe ich mich theoretisch...
Was ist denn FE?
Finance?
Nee, Frontend-Engineer.
Frontend?
Ah, Frontend sehe ich mich theoretisch nicht.
Okay.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, es ist Zeit, sich mit .NET und C-Sharp zu beschäftigen.
Wo wir uns ja einig sind, dass es die beste Programmiersprache ist.
Aber ich glaube, du musst erst mal den Bereich finden, der dir am meisten Bock macht und dir gefällt.
Weil dann kannst du dir auch ein paar Projekte überlegen.
Vielleicht hast du ja mega Bock auf Heimautomatisierung oder sowas.
Und willst Home Assistant Plugins bauen.
In Python. Kann ja auch sein.
Oder vielleicht willst du irgendwelche Machine Learning Sachen machen.
Microcontroller programmieren.
Es gibt ja tausend Varianten, was du machen kannst.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist jetzt erst mal rauszufinden, welcher Bereich dich eigentlich interessiert.
Consulting.
Es gibt kaum gescheite Consultants.
Okay, der Chat ist der Meinung, es kommt drauf an.
Ehrlich gesagt, als ich diese Option mit reingesetzt habe, war es mir klar, dass die gewinnt.
Also die meisten sind der Meinung, dass Codecamps...
Also es gibt kaum jemand, der meint, Codecamps sind Pog.
Viele sagen, alles Blödsinn.
Und... kommt drauf an.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an,
how er einen 32-Bit-Computer inside Terraria gebaut hat.
Ich würde sagen,
dass das so ohne weiteres gar nicht möglich ist.
Aber... prüfe... wie könnte man das auf Deutsch sagen?
Prüfe mich... prüfe mich falsch.
This is the single greatest achievement of my life to date.
As Gutenberg with his press or Eiffel with his tower,
I have brought forth my genius upon the world.
But you shouldn't be impressed because I spent 600 hours and 5 months...
Okay, er hat was gebaut in Terraria, wo man Pong draufspielen kann.
... in a Pong-Club.
You should be impressed because it's running on a computer
that is itself running inside of the game Terraria.
Dramatische Musik.
Zum Glück, zum Glück alte Musik und jemand...
What the fuck?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Ist das überhaupt noch Terraria?
Alter, jetzt aber gut hier.
Der hat's aber schon übertrieben, oder?
Mich wundert, dass das überhaupt läuft.
Wahrscheinlich drückt er auf Start und das Game laggt erst mal
oder freest erst mal für 30 Sekunden und dann...
und dann macht's ein... ein... ein Pong-Update oder so.
Und dann freest's wieder 30 Sekunden und dann macht's wieder ein Pong-Update.
Achso, was benutzt ihr für den Window-Manager, das Allerwichtigste?
Ja, ja, ihr habt recht, Chat.
Guck mal, ein i3-Enjoyer.
Okay, der hat was drauf, das sieht man gleich.
i3-En... i3-En... Enjoyer United hier.
So muss das sein.
Warum muss das überhaupt ein 32-Bit-Computer sein?
Warum kann's nicht einfach ein 8-Bit-Computer...
Für Pong reicht das ja schon.
Ja, bestimmt Arch-User, bestimmt Arch-User.
Was hat er denn da oben? Ist das Polybar?
Nee, was hat er denn da oben für eine...
Was hat er denn da oben für eine Statusleitung?
Was hat er da oben für eine Statusleiste, Chatge?
Es könnte sogar die normale i3-Statusleiste sein.
Let's go!
Aber i3-Enjoyer, schon mal nice.
First off, some background.
Terraria is a sandbox adventure game,
where you explore the world and fight bosses to progress.
You can basically think of it as a 2D-Minecraft-Clone,
although for some reason people get very mad on Reddit if they ever say so.
Inside the game, there's a mechanic called wiring,
which lets you trigger certain tiles, such as opening doors or activating traps.
When I say I've created a computer inside Terraria...
Okay, okay, okay. Nur, weil ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Also, im Prinzip ist das eine Mechanic, die nicht dafür gedacht ist,
um irgendwelche komplizierten Schaltungen in Terraria zu bauen.
Es ist mehr oder weniger so eine Geschichte von...
Wir legen ein Kabel, damit wir uns nicht selbst in die Luft sprengen,
sondern wir versuchen, die Kabel zu zerstören.
Okay, nice.
Dementsprechend wird die Performance beziehungsweise auch das Game explodieren,
wenn du da irgendwie den halben Bildschirm voll mit baust.
...such as opening doors or activating traps.
When I say I've created a computer inside Terraria,
what I mean is that I've completely simulated the inner workings of a regular computer.
Except, instead of electronics, I did it inside of a video game world.
But let's start at the beginning.
Okay, wie er im Thumbnail geschrieben hat,
Computer running a game running a computer running inside a game oder sowas.
Around five months ago, I was playing Terraria for a few hours
and I was getting a bit bored, so I decided to try out the wiring system on a whim.
At the beginning I knew pretty much nothing about it,
but I quickly realized it's super powerful
and you can do some really awesome things with it.
Here's a simple example.
Whenever you flip the switch, a signal is passed through the red wire
that opens and closes the door.
Leute, Achtung, jetzt, jetzt aufpassen, es wird pfeifert, pfeifertig.
Also jetzt brauchen wir allen IQ, den wir haben, dass wir das checken können.
High IQ only.
The same for turning on and off the candle.
Each different color of wire acts independently.
So if we cross the red and blue wire, they just ignore each other.
Es war eben was, wie viel, wie viel Stunden er ingame hat,
stand da eben irgendwo, wo, wo denn, hier, hier davor noch?
Ich wusste gar nicht, was ich tun soll, aber ich habe es schnell erkannt.
Es ist super mächtig und du kannst wirklich tolle Sachen damit machen.
Hier ist ein simples Beispiel.
Hier oder?
600 Stunden?
Hier meinste.
Terraria ist ein Sandbox-Adventure-Game,
in dem du die Welt erweckst und mit Bossen kämpfst, um zu überleben.
Du kannst es als 2D-Minecraft-Clone bezeichnen,
obwohl für irgendeinen Grund Leute auf Reddit sehr verrückt werden, wenn du das sagst.
Innerhalb des Spiels gibt es eine Mechanik namens Wiring,
mit der du bestimmte Teile triggerst,
z.B. Türen öffnen oder Tränen aktivieren.
Wenn ich sage, ich habe einen Computer in Terraria geschaffen,
meine ich, dass ich die inneren Arbeiten eines normalen Computers komplett simuliert habe.
Außer, anstatt Elektronik, habe ich es im Video-Game-Welt gemacht.
Aber fangen wir am Anfang an.
Etwa 5 Monate vor.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich habe Terraria für ein paar Stunden gespielt und...
Ach hier! 8372 Stunden!
Terraria Pro Gamer am Start.
Puh! Okay, das ist, das ist...
Das, das ist, das ist wirklich viel.
Also, der hat ziemlich genau ein Jahr durchgehend Terraria gespielt.
Und ich war ein bisschen müde.
Also habe ich entschieden, das Wiring-System auf dem Wimpern zu probieren.
Am Anfang wusste ich fast nichts darüber.
Aber ich habe schnell gemerkt, dass es super mächtig ist
und man mit ihm wirklich tolle Dinge machen kann.
Hier ist ein simples Beispiel.
Wann immer du den Schalter umdrehen kannst,
wird ein Signal durch das rote Wiring durchgeführt, das öffnet und schließt...
Dedication, ja?
Es ist das gleiche für das Umdrehen des Schalters.
Jedes unterschiedliche Farbe des Wiringes funktioniert unabhängig.
Also wenn wir über das rote und das blaue Wiring überschreiten,
ignorieren sie sich einfach.
Das grundlegendste Bildungsblock, mit dem die Computern umgesetzt werden,
ist der Logik-Gate.
Das sind kleine individuelle Units, die mehrere Inhalte einnehmen
und einen Ausdruck erzeugen, basierend auf sehr einfachem Logik.
Computern werden von extensiven Kombinationen dieser Gates hergestellt.
Terraria hat einige traditionelle Logik-Gate,
wie ein AND und ein OR,
aber für komplizierte und frustrierende Zeitbedingungen
sind diese sehr schwierig zu arbeiten.
Ich benutze für meinen Computer eine andere Art von Gate,
die so aussieht.
Es gibt drei Teile in jeder dieser Gates.
Die Input, die State und die Output.
Wann immer ein Schalter die Input auslöst,
wenn die State auf ist, erzeugt die Output ein Signal.
Sonst passiert nichts.
Zum Beispiel sieht man, dass die Tür nur öffnet und schließt,
wenn die State-Wire auf ist.
Also das ist jetzt quasi ein AND, oder was?
Nur wenn beide an sind, dann geht's auf.
In real life
In real world circuits,
when a circuit is on, it stays on.
But in Terraria, everything is just sent in pulses.
This means it behaves completely differently
and a lot of traditional circuits
have to be redesigned in this new paradigm.
Ne, hä? Dann hab ich's nicht gecheckt.
Egal, wir gucken einfach weiter.
You might think that we're just getting started, but that's it.
The entirety of the in-game CPU exclusively uses these gates
in various different, convoluted configurations.
And absolutely nothing else.
The complexity comes from the different ways
that these logic gates can interact with each other.
To give you an idea of how we can make interesting mechanisms
from these seemingly simple building blocks,
imagine chaining two of these gates together.
When the input triggers, it checks the first gate.
If that's activated, then it triggers the next gate,
which checks the other state.
Finally, if both are on, then the second gate emits a signal
and the door opens.
If you think about it, we've just created
the world's least secure combination lock.
All we have to do is change the direction of the switches
and hide the gates from the user.
And now only a single combination will allow entrances.
The length of the code can be extended
and the number of gates can be changed.
Back to when I was trying these gates for the first time,
as I was playing around with them,
I started getting really excited.
Just by tinkering around with these things,
I was able to get many basic, real-world circuits working
that are in every computer, like adders and multiplexers.
Making an actual computer with them
was the obvious next step,
but that's a massive jump in complexity from what I had.
So I decided to spend the next two weeks
putting in an unhealthy amount of hours
making a prototype.
This culminated in a...
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich da sehe.
Aber umso weiter man rauszoomt,
umso mehr sieht das tatsächlich
ein bisschen wie so einen Shot
von einer CPU aus.
Functional, albeit simple,
prototype computer.
Here you can see it calculating the Fibonacci numbers.
The A register shows the current value
in the sequence and B holds the next,
both in binary.
I've displayed the decimal versions below.
Naja gut, wenn das funktioniert,
dann würde ich sagen, als nächstes
braucht er einen GCC dafür,
dann kann er Linux verwenden,
dann kann er Linux kompilieren dafür,
dann kann er Java drauflaufen lassen
und dann Minecraft.
Dann hättest du Minecraft
auf Java-Basis in einem Linux
auf einem Computer in Terraria.
Auf geht's.
Oder zumindest Doom, genau.
Doom geht ja überall drauf.
Ich mein, Doom geht auf...
auf Tintenstrahldruckern.
Und angeblich sogar auf Schwangerschaftstests.
Was aber ein Fake war.
Computers, at least in high-level functionality,
are surprisingly simple.
Imagine a computer as a combination
of a button, a huge list of instructions,
a calculator and some scratch paper.
Every time the button is pressed,
the current instruction in the list
is fed into the calculator.
Ey, der hat sich mega Mühe
bei dem Video auch gegeben, gell?
...then the result is written onto the scratch paper
in case it might be used again later.
The next time the button is pressed
...the next instruction is executed.
At a very high level,
this is all that computers do.
Here we see that the computer
just loops endlessly,
That's quite simple,
but even programs as complicated
as the app or browser that you're watching
this video on are composed of millions
of simple instructions just like this.
Of course, computer engineers
instead of a button that you have to manually press
to execute the next instruction,
...computers have extremely fast...
Warum hast du keinen?
Ich brauche einen großen Taschenrechner selten.
Ich habe einen Taschenrechner,
aber so einen zwei Meter großen Taschenrechner
brauche ich selten. Okay, halben Meter
großen Taschenrechner.
...up to billions of times a second.
The list of instructions is the program you're executing.
War der nicht eben noch plott?
Ne, das war eindeutig gefärbte Haare, die der hatte, oder?
Das ist bestimmt das Gleiche.
Das Einzige, was auffällt, ist, dass der Typ
eine andere Haarfarbe hat.
The calculator is called the arithmetic logic unit, or ALU.
The scratch paper corresponds to registers,
which are like temporary buckets
you can store numbers in between calculations.
Finally, all the data being passed between
these components has been written here
in a human readable form.
But, because computers can only interpret 1s and 0s,
everything is represented in some kind of binary format.
How exactly each of these instructions
is encoded in 1s and 0s
is called the instruction set.
There's one other component component
to add to this model.
To actually organize the flow of data
between each of these modules, something called
the control unit is in charge of telling each
of the other components what to do and when.
It's kind of analogous to me, interfacing all
these components together in the demonstration.
This all seems pretty abstract,
but you can see exactly this layout
out in my prototype.
There's enough memory for 32 instructions,
each 8 bits long.
There's an ALU, which executes arithmetic instructions
such as addition, and it reads and writes
to a pair of registers labeled A and B.
Of course, it's not obvious
how breaking it down this way actually helps anything.
All we've done is take one hard problem
and converted it into
5 other also hard problems.
It feels like trying to cure yourself of syphilis
by infecting yourself with malaria.
It seems crazy like we're getting nowhere,
but it actually somehow works.
A lot of computer science
is basically that though.
Breaking hard problems into more manageable chunks.
Das stimmt, ja.
Unlike the open-ended task of building a computer,
have very well-defined inputs and outputs.
For example, to make a circuit
that adds two numbers, we know the exact rules
that govern addition, and we just have to get clever
in how we hook up the gates to match these rules.
Just like how we did for the combination lock earlier.
This is a compact circuit
to add two 1-bit numbers.
Obviously.
Cringe, wer das nicht erkennt,
dass das einfach zwei Nummern zusammenzählt.
Das ist eigentlich total offensichtlich.
...is a compact circuit
to add two 1-bit numbers.
There were a lot of problems
with this prototype, as expected.
Remember how I mentioned that only this specific
kind of logic gate should be used?
Making this prototype was where I realized
why the other ones don't work,
but not before some extensive cranial agitation
on my part for a few days.
The instruction set I used was custom-made
and very limited.
I was literally adding new operation codes
on a spreadsheet when I implemented that.
For my full-scale computer,
I wanted to implement a real-world instruction set.
I don't have time to go into exactly what this means,
but it involves far more work
ensuring complete compliance
to a strict standard.
Finally, performance-wise,
my prototype was pathetic.
My target for the full computer
was 100 kilobytes of memory
and far faster running speeds.
At this point, I had a plan
for the full-scale project,
now I just needed to implement it.
Building the full computer took a long time.
Like, a really long time.
There are mods and editors
and functionality, but any kind of circuitry
that isn't exactly copied
has to be redone by hand.
All in all, it took around 3 months of active development.
And along the way, I learned a huge amount
about digital logic and CPU design.
Surprisingly, spending 3 months playing Terraria
has improved my career prospects.
After all that, though,
I had finally done it.
I had designed and built a complete computer
from scratch in Terraria.
To give you a sense of scale,
here's the prototype I talked about earlier.
Here's how big it is
and here's the real size of the final version.
Looking back at projects like this
in hindsight always gives the sense
that things just work perfectly
in the first try, but they really, really don't.
I wanted to give you a small taste
of the pain I experienced debugging this behemoth.
So, let's look at this circuit, for example.
You can see the problem, right?
No? Well, you can...
Okay, Chad.
Wo ist das Problem?
Rechts oben ist das Problem.
Can you at least tell the difference
between the right and the left?
Okay, das ist eine rhetorische Frage,
weil er will, dass wir das nicht erkennen,
aber vielleicht erkennen wir es ja.
Okay, das ist incorrect.
Da steht er, hier steht er davor.
Vielleicht ist das Problem ja hier irgendwo.
Korrekt. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung.
Right and wrong version, right?
Still no?
Okay, fine. Let's zoom in a bit.
I'm sure now you can see the difference, right?
I'll even...
Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied.
Die Farbe von den grünen Kabeln ist anders.
Hä? Hä?
Hier ist grün und grün sind ein bisschen anders.
Aber das ist doch auch so.
Okay, ich hab keine Ahnung. Er wird es uns jetzt ja gleich zeigen.
I'll give you a few seconds.
The problem turned out to be that this green wire
was the wrong shade of green.
What?
Ich erkenne das nicht mal, wenn ich weiß, wo es ist.
Oh, tatsächlich, guck mal.
Grün, helleres Grün, dunkleres Grün.
Ja, aber ernsthaft, also...
Obviously, ja.
Okay, das ist wirklich fies.
The problem turned out to be that this green wire
was the wrong shade of green,
which meant that the whole thing worked unpredictably.
And I didn't even know where in the world it was.
It's like trying to find a needle in a haystack,
except that the needle is hay-shaped in amber
rather than the golden yellow that the hay is.
Grün, ich werde das nicht sehen.
Here comes the antagonist in our story, though.
Leg.
Imagine you spent months building this monster's creation
Und da geht es nicht.
Well, that's what would happen if you tried to run it.
It turns out, for reasons unbeknownst to me,
Terraria, an indie game from over a decade ago,
is not particularly well optimized
for massive wiring projects
Das dachte ich mir.
Das habe ich fast schon vermutet.
Weil die Dinger sind nicht für sowas gedacht.
Und dementsprechend auch nicht für sowas...
Also, das dachte ich mir,
dass das quasi erst mal 30 Sekunden hängt,
dann ein FPS quasi produziert in Pong, und dann...
...why it's so slow.
When the switch is pressed, just as before,
the door should open.
Every time the switch is pressed,
the game one by one looks at each wire along the way,
checks each of its neighbors,
and if it has any, tries to go down those as well.
It repeats this process all the way through
the entire length of the wire.
This wire is pretty short,
but when your computer is the size of a world,
going back and forth across thousands of tiles
from a game engine to a hall.
However, if the game just instead remembered
every time that this switch corresponded to this door
without manually checking each wire in between,
the game could run at much more reasonable speeds.
There are many other, more complicated optimizations
you can also do.
All of this logic is set by the developer...
Krass, man!
Die Leute haben das ja schon komplett wieder auseinandergenommen
und analysiert.
...inside the game, though.
So, there's nothing we can do about it.
A Terraria computer is just not realistically possible.
Or is it?
Naja, irgendwie muss es ja gehen.
Alter, warum haben die alle so krasse Setups?
Ich komme mir schon mit zwei Bildschirmen vor,
wie der übelste Hackerman.
Die haben immer alle einen Bildschirm oben,
noch einen Hochkant-Bildschirm.
Und eine Sache, die mich auch immer verwirrt ist,
dass die oftmals Tastaturen ohne Numblock haben.
Manchmal sogar auch ohne Pfeiltasten.
Klar, ich gette das schon,
man braucht das nicht unbedingt,
und das nimmt weniger Platz weg.
Aber ich mag den Numblock nicht,
weil ich glaube,
dass die sich nicht so gut befinden.
Numblock zum Tippen, tatsächlich.
Numblock ist POG.
Okay, der hat nicht nur den Computer gebaut,
der hat auch mal kurz noch einen Terraria-Mod gebaut,
dass es überhaupt möglich ist,
einen Computer in Terraria zu bauen.
Könnte auch sagen, es ist gecheatet.
Ja, schon. Aber wenn es anderweitig nicht geht.
Es ist nicht immer gleich, aber es ist viel, viel schneller.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man ohne den Accelerator-Mod läuft,
läuft der Computer bei 0,1 Instruktionen pro Sekunde.
Wenn ich den Mod benutze,
bekomme ich ca. 5000 Instruktionen pro Sekunde.
Um euch eine Idee zu geben,
wie schnell das ist,
ist das die Unterschiede in der Geschwindigkeit
zwischen einem 95-Jährigen,
der sich absolut auf die Straße bucht,
und einem supersonic Concorde-Airliner.
Das ist nicht eine metaphorische Vergleiche.
Die Ratio zwischen ihren Geschwindigkeiten
und ihren Geschwindigkeiten sind nicht gleich.
Aber das ist nicht alles.
Wenn ihr jetzt bestellt,
werde ich einen extensiven,
und extrem over-engineerten Software-Toolchain
für Minecraft-Mod geben.
Es gibt einen Minecraft-Mod,
wo man Minecraft in Minecraft spielen kann.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich gecheatet,
weil das Virtual Box laufen lässt unter der Haube,
und eigentlich nur die Grafik-Ausgabe
in Minecraft dann irgendwie reinmappt.
Das ist wirklich gecheatet.
Das hier nicht. Das nicht, so wirklich.
Also, er benutzt ja immer noch
Ingame-Sachen, nur halt
besser implementiert für diesen
Use Case.
Rust! Leute, endlich!
Da sind sie wieder!
Placingly Fast! Das ist der...
Rust ist der Grund, warum das funktioniert!
Placingly Fast,
written in Rust...
Ich verstehe nicht genau, was ich dort
sehend bin.
Github Actions
baut...
Dann ein Binary-File.
Das TXT-File wird eingelesen.
Er hat's wenigstens auch schon mal
in einer gescheiten Programmiersprache gemacht.
So you can use it to write arbitrary
binary programs into the computer's memory.
I've also written a high-level
and easy-to-use Rust application driver,
set up the official RISC-V Instruction Set
compliance test to run in-game,
and even published a Docker image
with continuous integration to automatically run regression tests
whenever the world has changed.
Das ist bestimmt ein neuer Job,
das ist ein nices Projekt,
kann man sich dann gut mitbewerben.
Das ist schon cool, aber
es ist auch ein schönes Beispiel für
wie sehr solche Dinge,
wenn man so verbissen
sich mit sowas beschäftigt,
wie sehr solche Dinge ausarten können
in Komplexität.
There's a ton of cool stuff here,
but I won't get into it in this video,
as I think more people are interested
in the Terraria part of the Terraria computer.
So just know that there's a lot of work
in the background to keep things running smoothly.
Enough wait, let's take a look
at what's possible with this thing.
I already showed Pong, so let's start there.
What's cool about Pong is that it runs
in real time and takes user input.
When I recorded this, I was in-game,
controlling the left paddle as it moved.
Movement of your Terraria character
is converted into wiring signals
Ich meine, das ist schon cool, oder?
interpreted as up or down,
which is why my character is jerking around like that.
It's unbelievably satisfying.
Ist schon nice, dass das funktioniert.
...to play a video game live
in a general purpose computer you made
inside another video game.
Another program I've written for my computer
is Conways Game of Life.
The Game of Life is a set of extremely simple rules
that produce fascinating patterns
when applied repeatedly to a grid of cells
that are either alive or dead.
Here you can see it running in-game.
Unfortunately, because it's quite computationally expensive,
it doesn't run very fast.
Even after I optimized the program for speed quite a bit,
this recording is sped up by 240 times.
I've saved the best for last.
So far, everything I've showed
has been pretty simple 2D programs.
But what if you could venture
into the third dimension?
Amazingly, even on a CPU as resource-limited as this,
you can.
Note that this isn't...
Na, wird doch Zeit für den GCC und Java
und Linux und Minecraft da drinne.
...just playing back a pre-recorded pixel video.
It's actually rendering a full 3D world
from the perspective of a certain XYZ coordinate
and displaying it on the screen.
As with the Game of Life, it's...
...too slow to run in real time, since it takes
45 seconds just to render a single thing.
Ah, okay. Moment. Das ist nicht mal
ein FPS. Das ist...
ähm... ja, keine Ahnung, was
das ist, aber 45 Sekunden
für ein FPS.
I can't take full credit here, though.
A friend of mine wrote this super-efficient program
and all I did was optimize it for this computer.
While not quite a simple
Doom clone yet, we're far closer to it
than I was expecting to be at the beginning of the project.
Krass.
Aber trotzdem heftig. Also...
Was das... dass das möglich ist?
A simple version of Terraria running inside
the game Terraria is definitely something
I want to do, and I'm pretty close.
It might take a bit more work in the accelerator,
but that's the obvious next milestone.
Everything I've done so far is open source
and available on public...
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, er muss Minecraft
inside Terraria laufen lassen.
If you're curious about this project, take a look
and check them out. The Rust interface
to write programs is quite easy to use
if you have even a bit of software experience.
It's a lot like writing a simple Arduino program.
I'm thrilled to see some more programs for you.
Mega nice.
If you've made it this far, thank you for watching.
Please like, subscribe, comment
and, I don't know, start my Github?
If you're interested in the details...
Ich stare sein Github.
Ah, ich bin nicht eingeloggt.
Ich stare trotzdem
sein Github.
Ach, ich bin auch nicht eingeloggt. Shit.
Ich kann sein Github nicht
starren. Ja.
Aber ich würde starren, wenn ich könnte.
Mach ich nachher im Stream.
Das hat er verdient.
Krasser Scheiß, Alter.
Die Leute.
Flip Mars, hat er noch mehr dazu?
Nö. Echt komplett gestörtes Zeug.
Wahnsinn.
Fifat.
Die Leute sind ja auch extrem...
Also,
Fifat reicht ja dafür schon gar nicht mehr aus.
Ultra high IQ.
Google hat auch
Zip Domains reinvented.
Leute, ich hab Hunger wie Sau.
Also, wir machen folgendes heute.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Und dann ist die Frage, ob ich das
hinkriege noch. Also, wenn ich
die Aufnahme hinbekommen hab und
die anderen Sachen, dann machen wir heute Abend vielleicht noch
Bastelstream. Ansonsten machen wir das
irgendwann unter der Woche.
Muss ich mal gucken.
Aber vielleicht klappt das heute Abend noch. Was wird
gebastelt? Wir versuchen die
9-Euro-Steckdose zu flashen.
Und gucken,
ob das mit Zigbee und dem
Thermostat
geht und solche Geschichten. Aber erstmal gucken wir,
dass wir die Steckdose geflasht kriegen.
Die hat einen ESP866
drauf. Also, prinzipiell sollte das
möglich sein. Okay, Chatge,
wir sehen uns. Macht's gut. Bis denn. See you.
Outro